.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
APRIL EIGHTEENTH
MEETING OF BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE.
I'M SORRY THAT WE'RE STARTING A
LITTLE BIT LATE BUT.
.
WE'RE GONNA I TAKE THINGS A
LITTLE BIT OUT OF ORDER BECAUSE.
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY.
SLEPT A LITTLE LATE THIS MORNING
PARA.
AND TO A MS ROSS YOU'RE GOOD
ENOUGH TO RUSH OVER. AT MY
REQUEST THAT WE CAN SKIP FORWARD
AND BEGIN WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
OKAY OKAY FLOORS HOURS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF I'M
JUST GONNA FUNDS WILL BE JUST A
FOR THE RECORD.
PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A HAVE A QUARREL A
COMMITTEE HERE YET SO WILL
ATTACK ROLE SINCE WE HAVE A.
A CORE PRESENT CAN THAT WILL.
THE TICKET TESTIMONY IN THE
METER OKAY ALRIGHT SO I'M JUST
GOING TO JUMP RIGHT INTO THAT
ITEMS AS THEY'RE. LISTED FOR
TIME FOR DISCUSSION. I'M I'M
GOING TO START WITH OUR BE SAFE
PROGRAM.
THIS IS AN.
A A VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM FOR
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE AS WE
KNOW.
WITH ALL OF OUR SPECIALTY CROPS
WERE VERY DEPENDENT ON HONEY
BEES AND POLLINATORS AND THIS IS
A PROGRAM. THAT'S REQUESTING
ONE.
ONE MILLION EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND. AND TWO POSITIONS FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
FOR US TO MANAGE A P. SAFE
PROGRAM AT DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY
FOR SEVERAL OBJECTIVES ARM ONE
IS TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND
SURVIVAL OF HONEYBEES BY
INCREASING FORAGING
OPPORTUNITIES.
REDUCING PESTICIDE EXPOSURE AND
PROVIDING FUNDS TO LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT THIS WOULD BE
THROUGH OUR COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER OFFICES.
.
TO DO THE WORK OF ENFORCING THE
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS
ON THIS WILL ALSO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT OF TECHNICAL
RESOURCES FOR DATABASE
DEVELOPMENT AND DATA ENTRY TOOLS
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR AG
COMMISSIONERS TO WORK ACROSS
COUNTY LINES TO COORDINATE THIS
PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT DOES
NOT HAVE THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY
TO CHARGE A FEE FOR BEEKEEPING
AND HONEY BEES WHICH DO PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC BENEFIT TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT'S FOR A VERY OBVIOUS
REASON.
THE BEGINNING OF EVERY YEAR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS HOST TO
THE WORLD'S LARGEST POLLINATOR
PROJECT. WHEN WE ACTUALLY HAVE
OVER A MILLION ALMOST TWO
MILLION HONEY BEE HIVES IN THE
STATE DOING THE THINGS THAT
HONEY BEES DO. HALF OF THOSE
OVER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND BUT A
LOT OF SONGS WRITTEN ABOUT YEAH
I IT'S JUST GREAT FODDER SO TO
SPEAK FOR ALL KINDS OF POETRY
AND AND SONG WRITING.
BIT OVER HALF OF THOSE HONEY
BEES ARE COMING FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AT SOME.
THE IT INDUSTRY A PICKUP
BEEKEEPERS MANY MANY SMALL VERY
INDEPENDENT OPERATORS FROM ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. ARM AND WE
DON'T HAVE THE THE REACH TO
THOSE OUT OF STATE PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO ENFORCE ITS KINDA
REGISTRATION PROGRAM. BUT WE'RE
HOPEFUL WITH THIS PROGRAM AND
PIPE REALLY KEEPING A FOCUS WITH
A COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS OFFICES THAT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO ENFORCE THE
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENT WHICH
WE BELIEVE WILL BE BENEFICIAL TO
THE BEE KEEPERS THEMSELVES.
FIRST OF ALL OVER RECENT YEARS
EVERY TIME I GO OUT AND SPEAK
WITH PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE WE
HAVE AN INCREASED INCIDENCE OF
THEFT OF HONEY BEE HIVES.
AND THEY'RE VERY VALUABLE BULLET
ALSO FOUND THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE
JUST PLACING HIVES.
SPORADICALLY WITHOUT ANY
COORDINATION WITH THE LOCAL AT
COMMISSIONER OFFICE OR WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE THE LAND OWNERS.
THERE IN AREAS THAT ARE
CONFLICTING WITH PEST MANAGEMENT
OPERATIONS ON NEIGHBORING
GROUNDS SO THE REGISTRATION
PROGRAM IS VERY KEY FOR US ON
THAT'S.
WE ALSO WANT TO USE THIS
PROGRAM AS A WAY TO MAP OUT
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES TO REALLY
ENHANCE FORAGING OPPORTUNITIES
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE HONEY BEES
HAVE GOOD NUTRITION WHILE THEY
ARE IN OUR STATE. AS WELL AS WE
THINK THIS WILL HELP US ALSO
IMPROVE FORAGING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR NATIVE POLLINATOR HABITAT.
AS WELL.
SO THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE P.
SAFE PROGRAM TO MEDICAL THROUGH
ALL OF THE SORT YOU WANT ME TO
STOP AFTER EACH ONE.
FOR I WOULD LIKE YOU TO GO
THROUGH ALL OF THEM BUT TO TAKE
A BREATH BECAUSE I DO HAVE A
QUESTION THAT.
AND.
THAT IS THERE'S A. A.
COMMENT.
A STAFF COMMENT THAT.
TALKS ABOUT TO.
THE.
OF FUNDA I THINK THAT WOULD
ANNOYED WHEN THE WRONG TERM ON
THE WRONG PAGE.
GIVE ME ONE MOMENT.
THERE'S A COMMENT ABOUT.
STAT ARE A GIVING CONSIDERATION
TO THE COST TO OPERATE THIS
PROGRAM THAT.
APPROACH TO BE IT SHOULD BE
SHARED WITH BEEKEEPERS AND I'M
WONDERING IF YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS. ON THE MAJOR THOUGHT
AS BECAUSE WE HAVE OVER HALF OF
THE POPULATION OF BEES COMING
FROM BEE KEEPERS OUT OF STATE
THAT'S THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
PRESS AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO ASSESS.
THE AT THIS MOMENT.
OKAY.
ARE THERE OTHER QUESTIONS.
ELIOT ONE ASIDE AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND. WE'RE RECOMMENDING
THE APPROVE WHEN YOUR FUNDING TO
ESTABLISH THE BE SAFE PROGRAM
THAT WE THINK IT IS PROGRAM
WOULD HELP COUNTY AGRICULTURE
AND RURAL COMMISSIONERS. ADDRESS
A NUMBER OF THREATS TO THE
STATE'S BE POPULATION INCLUDING
DIOP'S FROM CONTRACT WITH
PESTICIDES. THAT ARE TOXIC TO BE
IS IN THE IDENTIFICATION. OF
PASSED IN DISEASES THAT CAN
AFFECT BEES. I'M HOWEVER WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER ITS OPTIONS REGARDING
HOW TO TELL A FUND TO BE SAY
PROGRAM GOING FORWARD. AND
THOUGH IT'S APPROPRIATE DEFINE
THAT THE PROGRAM WITH GENERAL
FUND DUE TO THE WIDE BENEFIT
THAT BEES PROVIDE. AYE WE ALSO
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE FUND THE
PROGRAM USING FEE REVENUES FROM
REGULATED BEE KEEPERS WHO WOULD
BE THE MAIN BENEFICIARIES OF THE
PROGRAM.
AND SO THEREFORE WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DROP TAPE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE CDF
AGED TO PROVIDE REPORT. TO THE
LEGISLATURE AS SPECIFICALLY WILL
REQUIRE PUTTING ON ANNUAL
REVENUES COLLECTED UNDER THE
CURRENT.
APIARY REGISTRATION FREE CANDY
COST ADMINISTER THE APIARY
REGISTRATION FREE AND OPTIONS TO
ALIGN FEE REVENUES WITH COUNTY
COSTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES. AND
FUND THIS PROGRAM THROUGH
THROUGH FEES AND SO UNDER THIS.
PROPOSAL YOU WOULD HAVE THAT
FUNDING FOR ONE YEAR AND THEN
YOU'D HAVE MORE INFORMATION NEXT
YEAR IN THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
HAD OF INFORMATION TO DECIDE.
WHETHER THIS PROGRAM SHOULD BE
FUNDED ENTIRELY THROUGH GENERAL
FUND ENTIRELY THROUGH FEES ARE A
MIX.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FUTURE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE THINK
THAT THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES A
BROAD PUBLIC BENEFIT SO WE THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO. FUND A
PROGRAM WITH ONGOING GENERAL
FUND OF IT IN ADDITION TO
PROVIDING LIMITED TERM FUNDING
MAY POSE CHALLENGES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF AND TRYING TO FILL
THE POSITIONS. IT IN A. SO
YOU'RE SAYING THAT.
ONE YEAR FUNDING WOULD HAVE
THAT TO.
IT IS NOT AN INTERN FUNDING I
THINK AS WITH AL ALL OF THE
PROPOSALS.
MAY MAKE IT HARD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO FILL THE POSITIONS
BUT I THINK THE MAIN. POINT IS
THAT.
THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES A BROAD
PUBLIC BENEFIT AND WE THINK THAT
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO USE GENERAL
FUND TO FUND ON AN ONGOING
BASIS.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE A REPORTING
LANGUAGE ANY ISSUES WITHOUT.
.
I THINK THAT.
AND MANY IF.
IF TO THE EXTENT THAT IT.
RESULTS AND WORKLOAD THAT MIGHT
NOT BE OBSERVABLE WE WOULD HAVE
CONCERNS.
I THINK. THAT. IF A IF THE
DEPARTMENT HAS THE.
ABILITY TO.
DO THAT WITHIN EXISTING
RESOURCES WELL WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE CONCERNS BUT.
BUT AGAIN WE WOULD.
.
WE SUPPORT THE A PROPOSED%
PROPOSAL US REQUESTED WITH ON
GOING TO AND FROM OKAY THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE A RECOMMENDATION HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN THAT'S WITH A
CABLE DO TODAY.
ISSUE THREE.
SHORT SO THE NEXT ONE.
IS AS DEALING WITH OUR PLIGHT
BORDER PROTECTION STATION.
UMP THE PROPOSAL REQUEST NINE
MILLION THREE HUNDRED FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR THE ACQUISITION OF
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE ACRES OF LAND.
WEST OF A VERY AGING AND
ANTIQUATED. BORDER PROTECTION
STATION ON IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
THIS IS ON INTERSTATE TEN.
INTERSTATE TEN IS THE MAIN
FREEWAY THAT CONNECTS THE PORTS
OF LOS ANGELES AND THE PORTS OF
LONG BEACH WITH ARIZONA NEW
MEXICO TEXAS LOUISIANA
MISSISSIPPI ALABAMA AND FLORIDA.
SO THIS IS A MAJOR TRADE QUARTER
AS WELL AS HEAVY TOURISM
TRAFFIC.
SO WHEN THIS WHEN THIS BORDER
STATION WAS BUILT IN NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE WE WERE PASSING
THROUGH ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND VEHICLES A YEAR. AND IN
THE MORE RECENT YEARS WE ARE
OVER FIVE MILLION VEHICLES A
YEAR SO IT REPRESENTS PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUES AS WELL AS
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS FOR TRAVELERS
AND TRUCKERS WHO ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS FACILITY.
ONCE THIS LAND IS ACQUIRED ON
OUR INTENT IS TO PROPOSED
CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW
APPROXIMATELY NINE THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT FACILITY WITH OFFICE
SPACE. AIR CONDITIONING
APPROPRIATE LIGHTING.
AN EMERGENCY GENERATOR TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AS WELL AS OUR
EMPLOYEE SAFETY ISSUES AT THE
WHITE BORDER PROTECTION STATION.
THANK YOU AND THAT'S A GOOD TO
ADD DOES THE LA OUR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE HAVE COMMENTS ON THIS.
TO SECURE TIME FOR US TO PAUSE
AND TO FORM A QUORUM WELCOME
MISTER KALRA.
YOUR PHONE.
BLOOM.
HERE FONG. KALRA. MULLIN
PATTERSON.
AND ON THIS ITEM WE HAVE FOR A
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE THIS
BUDGET IS THERE A MOTION TO THAT
EFFECT.
THEIR SECOND.
SIR.
THANK YOU.
BLOOM.
I FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
THANK YOU A ISSUE POOREST.
OUR ONGOING BATTLE WITH THE.
.
A CITRUS CECIL ANOTHER PASS.
YES SO THIS IS A PROPOSAL THAT
REQUEST TWO AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
AUTHORITY AND TWO AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND AGRICULTURAL FUND AUTHORITY
AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FOR OUR ONGOING AND
INCREASINGLY COMPLEX BATTLE WITH
THE ASIAN CITRUS CELL AND WHICH
VECTORS THE TREE KILLING LONG
LONG BEING TO SEIZE. UP WE ARE
HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO NOT
FOLLOW IN FLORIDA'S PATHWAY WE
ARE GOING TO PROTECT THE CITRUS.
GROWTH IN OUR STATE AND ALL OF
THE CITRUS TREES IN A
RESIDENTIAL AREAS ON IT'S A BIG
PROGRAM AND IT CONTINUES TO
EVOLVE AND BECOME EVEN MORE
COMPLEX.
BUT I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
INVESTMENT BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND IMPORTANTLY THE INVESTMENT
BY THE CITRUS INDUSTRY ITSELF.
AS WELL AS FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THE
RESEARCH PROGRAM. ARE WORKING WE
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN STANDING
UP A PROGRAM. AND KEEPING THE
DISEASE OUT OF COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTION AREAS. THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE FOR US IN
THIS PROGRAM EVEN SINCE THE TIME
THAT THE ORIGINAL PCP WAS. PUT
TOGETHER IS THAT. IN ADDITION TO
AN INCREASING POPULATION OF THAT
ASIAN CITRUS SALAD WHICH HAS
EXPANDED POINTING REGIONS AROUND
THE STATE. WE NOW HAVE.
ONE LONG BEING IT'S CURRENTLY
IN RESIDENTIAL AREAS ONLY AND
THE LA BASIN WE WANT TO KEEP IT
SEPARATED FROM THE COMMERCIAL
CROWS. ON BUT IT IS A VERY LABOR
INTENSIVE PROGRAM OF SURVEYING
FOR THE DISEASE ITSELF. AND IT
HAS INCREASED TREMENDOUSLY THE
WORKLOAD FOR LABORATORIES DOING
THE DIAGNOSTICS TO RUN THAT
DISEASE. IDENTIFICATION PROCESS
AND THEN BEING ABLE TO TAKE THE
ACTIONS TO PULL THOSE TREES OUT.
SO IT HAS INCREASED IT IS AN
EVOLVING PROGRAM BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT WITH THIS PROPOSAL OF TWO
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS OF
GENERAL FUND IN ADDITION TO TWO
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS. FROM
THE AD FUND THAT WE WILL HAVE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO CONTINUE
TO. FIGHT THE PROGRAM THAT HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFUL SO FAR WE ARE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CITRUS.
COMMITTEE AND DOING ITS
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT HAS FACTORED
IN THIS NEW FINDING AT THE
DISEASE AND RESIDENTIAL AREAS
AND HOW THAT MIGHT NEED SOME
ADJUSTMENTS IN OUR PROGRAM GOING
FORWARD. ON IT'S AN INTENSIVE
PROGRAM IT'S REQUIRING A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND ESPECIALLY ITS IN
PINK.
CREASING THE LOAD ON OUR
LABORATORIES TO BE ABLE TO RUN
ALL THE DIAGNOSTICS THAT WERE
DOING THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THAT.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES.
JUST IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS CAME
OUT WITH A REPORT THAT'S REALLY
LOOKING AT THE RESEARCH WHAT ARE
THE LONG TERM SOLUTIONS TO THE
US WE DON'T YET HAVE THEM. BUT I
BELIEVE BASED ON THE EXPERIENCE
AND THE SUCCESS THAT WE'VE SEEN
IN THE PIERCE'S DISEASE PROGRAM.
IN THE EUROPEAN GRAPE VINE MOTH
PROGRAM THAT WE'RE PUTTING
RESEARCH DOLLARS AND THE RIGHT
KINDS OF THINGS WE NEED MORE
EARLY DETECTION TOOLS TO ASSIST
THE INDUSTRY OF MAKING THEIR OWN
MANAGEMENT DECISIONS. IN
ADDITION TO RESEARCH TO IMPROVE
THE PARIETALS THAT ARE BEING
OFFERED THAT WILL BE RESISTANT
TO THE DISEASE ONE LONG BEING
ITSELF SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE AWARE THAT
WHILE THIS IS AN INCREASINGLY.
COMPLEX IN LARGER PROGRAM WE
HAVE REALLY MADE THE INVESTMENTS
I BELIEVE IN THE RIGHT KINDS OF
PLACES TO PROTECT THE COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTION OF CITRUS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
HAS SOME COMMENTS ON THE
ASSEMBLY AND SHAWMUT WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WE'RE RECOMMENDING YOU APPROVE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. GIVEN
THE RECENT INCREASES IN THE
SQUARE MILES UNDER QUARANTINE
FOR BETH EIGHT PATIENTS INTEREST
SELIGMAN LUNG BANG. THAT THE
GROWING NUMBER OF TREES INFECTED
WITH ONE ONE THING OF THE PAST
FEW YEARS IN THE THREAT IT
NATION'S INTERESTS RELATIVE AND
LOT ONE MONTH BEING POSED TO THE
STATE'S CITRUS INDUSTRY. WITHIN
THREE QUEST IT'S IS REASONABLE
WOULD ALSO RECOMMENDED THAT THAT
MEASURES IT HAS IN PLACE ARE
ARE.
IN CURRENTLY IMPLEMENTING ARE
SUFFICIENT TO SUPPRESS THAT
ANNA.
A SENSITIVE SELIGMAN LONG RUN
BEING WHETHER THEY'RE ADDITIONAL
MEASURES THE STATE SHOULD
CONSIDER. AND.
AND WHAT WOULD BE THE COSTS OF
IMPLEMENTING ANY SUCH MEASURES.
THANK YOU THIS DEPARTMENT
VANESSA COMMITS.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM DYESS.
I KNOW THAT THIS IS THE ISSUE OF
FOR A GREAT INTEREST TO.
A TO THE CITRUS INDUSTRY I
SHOULD HAVE PAUSED AFTER ISSUE
THREE SINCE WE TOOK ACTION ON
THAT ITEM TO ASK FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT.
BUT IF THERE IS A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUES NUMBER TWO
THREE OR FOUR WHEN WE TAKE THAT
AT THIS TIME.
WHILE YOU'RE STEPPING FORWARD.
ALTHOUGH.
WE HAVE ONE PERSON OF STEPPING
FORWARD.
MAYBE NOT SO INTENSE BUT BEFORE
BEFORE EACH SPEAK I JUST WEST OF
THE RECOMMENDATION ON THIS WAS
TO APPROVE IT BUDGETED.
BASED ON COMMENTS THAT I'VE
ALREADY RECEIVED FROM THE
INDUSTRY.
WHO HAVE BEEN?
PUTTING A LOT OF MONEY INTO
THIS ISSUE.
I THAT THEY THINK THAT OF THE
AMOUNT THAT WE ALLOCATE. A. A
SHOULD BE GREATER.
AT I WANT TO GIVE SOME TIME TO
ALLOW CONSIDERATION OF.
OF FOR A POTENTIAL ADDITIONAL
BUDGET ALLOCATION ON THIS
ON BOTTOM IS SORT AND HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN HAPPIER FOR ME NOW.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO ARE
KNOWN HE JAKE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE HOLDING THE
ITEM OPEN AND HAVING A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME. TO DISCUSS THIS
ISSUE AND YOU KNOW WALKING INTO
THIS YEAR THIS YEAR WE KNEW THAT
THE.
SPREAD OF THE DISEASE IN THE
BUD WAYS.
GROWING BUT WE WERE LOOKING AT
MEASUREMENT.
OPERATIONS THAT WE. GLAZER
CONTAINING AND WHAT WE'RE DOING
UNFORTUNATELY RECENTLY FOUND OUT
YOU KNOW AT THIS TIME LAST YEAR
WE HAD FIFTY THREE FINES OF LONG
LONG BEING. AND WE RECENTLY JUST
FOUND OUT THAT NOW WE'RE AT OVER
SIX HUNDRED. OF ONE LONG BEING
AND SO ON THE PROBLEM HAS JUST
EXPANDED DRAMATICALLY AND FOR
THAT REASON WE JUST APPRECIATE
YOU HOLDING IT OPEN AS YOU SAID
THE CITRUS INDUSTRY HAS PUT A
LOT OF THEIR OWN FUNDS INTO THIS
PROGRAM THEY'VE ALSO HELPED FIND
A NEW RESEARCH FACILITY DOWN AT.
UC RIVERSIDE SPECIFICALLY TO GO
TOWARDS TRYING TO FIND A CURE
FOR THIS DISEASE IN WHAT WE CAN
DO YOU.
AND THEN ALSO JUST LOOKING FOR
FUNDS TO HELP CFA BE ABLE TO PUT
THEIR.
.
PUT MORE RESOURCES INTO THIS
PROGRAM HAVE MORE DEDICATED
STAFF TO THIS PROGRAM. SO THAT
WE CAN REALLY CONTAIN THE
DISEASE AND CONTINUE WORKING ON
A CURE AND KEEP IT OUT OF OUR
COMMERCIAL GROVES WHICH.
IS ABOUT A THREE POINT. THREE
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY SO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE APPRECIATE
THAT AND WE APPRECIATE THAT.
COMMITTEE FOR ON TAKING SOME
MORE TIME TO LOOK INTO THIS
ISSUE.
BOB PAUL TOWERS WITH BE SMART
CALIFORNIA AND PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK AS WELL AS A CENTER FOR
FOOD SAFETY SINCE THEY'RE NOT
HERE.
WANTING TO I SHARE. ARE A
COMMITMENT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGRICULTURE TO KEEPING
CALIFORNIA'S BE
SAFE.
LUCKILY OUR COMMERCIAL HONEYBEES
AS WELL AS OUR NATIVE
POLLINATORS
AS WELL AS PROVIDING FORT
OPPORTUNITIES CAN FORGE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE STATE'S
BEES.
US WILL CHALLENGES WE HAVE WITH
THE PROPOSAL AS OUTLINES
I'M IS THAT'S
THE.
KERN PROPOSAL AND THE WAY THAT
WE WARN BEEKEEPERS AND ENCOURAGE
THEM TO MOVE THEIR BEES
IGNORES THE PERSISTENCE OF MANY
OF THE PRODUCTS THAT ARE USE.
I MEAN HE'S PRODUCTS RESIDE FOR
HOURS IF NOT DAYS AFTERWARDS AND
CONTINUE TO THREATEN NOT ONLY
COMMERCIAL BEES OP BUT ACTUALLY
CONTINUE TO THREATEN NATIVE
PIECE THAT CAN'T BE E. I
RELOCATED.
I IN ADDITION WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE LACK OF INVESTMENT AND
FORGE OPPORTUNITIES
S. LOOKING A FISH AND GAME LAND
FISH WILDLIFE PLAN IS NOT
ENOUGH.
CONTINUED LOOK ON OUR OWN FARMS
FOR SOLUTIONS AYE WE SEE IS THE
A RIPE AREA FOR INVESTMENT.
SO THOSE ARGUMENTS AND ITEM
NUMBER TWO IN TERMS OF ITEM
NUMBER I TH FOR AND WE ARE.
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT WE SHARE THE CONCERNS ABOUT
SIX I AGENTS IT RESULTED IN ONE
MONTH BEING OUT WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN IN THE STATE'S
OUGHT TO KEEP THE PASSED OUT.
BUT I THINK THE CHALLENGE WE
FACE IN TRYING TO CONTROL CITRUS
THOUGH IT AND THE DISEASE IS
THAT WE MIGHT USE TOOLS THAT DO
MORE HARM THAN GOOD AND ONE OF
THOSE TOOLS IS BANNED. AYE
CORPORATE FAUCET NEUROTOXIC
PESTICIDE
I THAT THE STATE IS CURRENTLY
EVALUATING AYE THE DEPARTMENT
HAS THAT REGULATION. AYE AND SO
IT WAS MEANT TO BE SLATED FOR
BAND AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND SO
WE AS WE SEE CONTINUED USE OF
THIS PRODUCT FOR CONTROLLING
CITRUS PSYLLID WE'VE CONCERNS
ABOUT CONTINUING TO FUND. THIS
PROGRAM IN THIS WAY AND SO I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A COMMITMENT
TO NOT USING THAT HARMFUL
PESTICIDE THAT POSES NUNLEY
THREATS TO PEACE BUT TO TO AYE.
TO PEOPLE AS WELL.
SARIA I WAS DISTRACTED WHEN YOU
BEGAN SPEAKING COULD YES LE REAP
A SHAVE YOUR NAME AND OBSERVERS
UPON PAUL TOWERS FOR THE FIRST
ITEM I'M WITH THE SMART
CALIFORNIA.
THIS SITE ACTION NETWORK AYE AND
THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY FOR
THE SECOND ITEM CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM.
HOLLY FOR MANY WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF A
CALIFORNIA STATE BEEKEEPERS
ASSOCIATION DAY.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BCP BUT WE
WERE I'M ALSO HOPING THAT THE
ASSEMBLY WOULD CONSIDER
ADDITIONAL FUNDING I'M FOR THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A LONG
AWAITED THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT FOR YEARS ON
SEVERAL INEFFICIENCIES
ESPECIALLY AT THE BORDER
STATIONS WITH INSPECTIONS.
I'M IN FUNDING HAS BEEN THE
NUMBER ONE CONCERN AND REASON
WHY WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO. DO
MORE TO ENSURE.
A SWIFTER AND TRENDS INTO A
INTO THE STATE AND INTO ON THE
COUNTY SO WE'RE HOPING THAT
THERE BE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
INCLUDED FOR THAT. AS WELL AS
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
RULE CRIMES TASK FORCE STILL BE
HIVE THEFT IS HAPPENING ALL OVER
THE STATE ESPECIALLY DURING THE
SEASONS I AM. WITH ALMONDS
MINIVAN FOR BEES TO BE IN THE
ALMONDS OR HOPING FOR MORE
FUNDING FOR THAT AND FOR MANY OF
LEGISLATION WE PASSED OVER THE
YEARS. ON GRANTING MORE ACCESS
TO PUBLIC LANDS STATE AND
FEDERAL LANDS WE'VE GOT
LEGISLATION ON THE BOOKS THAT
HASN'T BEEN IMPLEMENTED
EFFECTIVELY AND WE HOPE WITH
THIS PROGRAM IN THE STAFFING THE
WILL BE ABLE TO ENSURE MORE
EFFECTIVE USE OF OUR PUBLIC
LANDS AGAIN WE SUPPORT THE BCP
BUT HOPE. YOU WOULD CONSIDER
ADDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT
WE FOR PRESIDENTIAL ONE POINT
TWO MILLION HOPEFULLY ON TO MAKE
IT A ROOM ROBUST AND
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO AND
THE BASIC PROGRAM THANK YOU.
DENNIS ALL THE ON THE ON THE
HEALTH THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE WE
AGREE WITH THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
WE PROVIDED. OF A HOST OF.
BCP AUGMENTATIONS TO THE STAFF
AND MANY OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE YOU
REVIEWING THOSE HOLLY WENT
THROUGH THOSE VERY WELL.
AND AGAIN.
POLLINATOR HEALTH AND BE HEALTH
IS VERY IMPORTANT THE ALLMAN
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS. OF THE
ENTIRE. PLANT BASED AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY.
ON ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH OF
THE BORDER STATION HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA GRAIN FEED.
CALIFORNIA SEEDS SUCH AS WE JUST
TALK ABOUT.
BUT ISSUES AT THE BE HEALTH WE
TALK ABOUT ONE LONG BEING AND
YOU'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT ANIMAL
HEALTH LATER. ALL THOSE ISSUES
ARE CRITICAL OF THE BORDER
STATIONS TO PREVENT. INVASIVE
PLANTS AND A.
A.
PASSED TO COMMENT BUT ALSO
ANIMAL DISEASES AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT NEEDS TO BE UPDATED
ALLOW FOR BETTER THROUGHPUT BUT
ALSO ALLOW FOR OPPORTUNITIES. TO
BE ABLE TO.
DIVERT FOLKS AND AND HOLD THEM
OFF WHEN THERE ARE ISSUES SUCH
AS A. CONTAMINATED PRODUCTS
COMING INTO THE STATE'S HELP A
WE ALSO SUPPORT THANK.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TO SHOULD GUARANTEE WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF CDF A QUEST ON THAT.
AT BCP FOR PATENT THE BE SAFE
PROGRAM AND ALSO THE
AUGMENTATION REQUESTED BY THE
PREVIOUS TWO SPEAKERS THANK YOU.
GREAT
EDU.
LET'S MOVE ONTO A ISSUE.
WHERE IS YOUR FIVE?
FIVE.
THEORY IS IT IS A NEW REQUEST
OUT DEVELOPMENT A PESTICIDE
ALTERNATIVES.
ON THIS IS A PROPOSAL THAT
REQUEST FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
IN ONE POSITION FOR FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. AN ON
GOING FOR US OFFICE OF PESTICIDE
CONSULTATION AND ANALYSIS
TO SUPPORT THE SCIENTIFIC
DEVELOPMENT AND TESTING OF
ALTERNATIVE PEST MANAGEMENT
TOOLS. UP WITH THAT WITH A FOCUS
ON BIO CONTROL EFFORTS.
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE IS VERY
BOUNTIFUL IN THE STATE WE HAVE
OVER FOUR HUNDRED SPECIALTY
CROPS.
THAT MEANS I OFTENTIMES THE ONLY
PLACE SOME OF THESE CROPS ARE
GROWN ARE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT EVEN IF
THEY'RE LARGE A CREATURE. IN
CALIFORNIA ON A NATIONAL SCALE
IT'S VERY HARD SOMETIMES TO
ATTRACT. THE ATTENTION AND THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT OF SOME
THE MANUFACTURES OF PEST
MANAGEMENT TOOLS TO CREATE
PRODUCTS FOR SPECIALTY CROPS.
BOB THIS IS A PROGRAM DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE PRESSURES THAT ARE ON OUR
HISTORIC PEST MANAGEMENT TOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA WELL WE ARE THE
NUMBER ONE AGRICULTURAL STATE BY
LEAPS AND BOUNDS WERE ALSO HOME
TO FORTY MILLION RESIDENTS. AND
THAT GROWING POPULATION AND LAND
USE DEVELOPMENT PATTERNS HAVE
PUT A LOT OF UNUSUAL PRESSURES
ON THE USE OF OUR. TRADITIONAL
PEST MANAGEMENT TOOLS AND WE
HAVE PRODUCTS THAT ARE LEGALLY
REGISTERED BUT HAVE MEDICATION
MEASURES ARE ARE FACING
POTENTIAL T. REGISTRATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS IS.
THING MODEST PROPOSAL BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT AND HOPEFULLY
LEVERAGE GRANT FUNDS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AS WELL AS.
COORDINATING WITH THE COMMODITY
GROUPS.
TO ACCELERATE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF ALTERNATIVE PEST MANAGEMENT
TOOLS THROUGH A PROGRAM THAT'S
ACTUALLY AUTHORIZED TO THE FARM
BILL ALSO IT'S TIMELY AND
TALKING ABOUT THIS TODAY BECAUSE
ARE STARTING THE DISCUSSIONS ON
THE FARM BELT. CALLED UP BY OUR
FOR PROGRAM. UPDATES ON A
REGIONAL BASIS HISTORICALLY
CALIFORNIA ON THE WEST COAST
DOESN'T GET WHAT WE THINK IS OUR
FAIR SHARE OF AYE ARE FOUR
DOLLARS AND WE THINK THAT HAVING
THE STATE INVESTMENT WILL HELP
US LEVERAGE. GETTING MORE
INVESTMENT PRODUCTS FOR THE
SPECIALTY CROPS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE WEST COAST
SO WITH THIS WE BELIEVE WE CAN
MAKE A GOOD START ON HELPING THE
INDUSTRY IDENTIFY PRIORITY
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE IN THE
PIPELINE AND ACCELERATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THEM. AND
BRINGING THEM TO COMMERCIAL USE
ON OUR FARMS AND RANCHES.
THANK YOU HAVE A RECOMMENDATION
TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
JUST A LAYOVER HOW*
COMMENTS OR DEPARTMENT THAT'S.
SEEING NONE.
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM
WHICH DOES HAVE A RECOMMENDATION
TO APPROVE ITS BUDGET THAT.
.
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT TO AT
THE END OF THIS ITEM ON.
BOTH ISSUES FIVE AND SIX.
SELECT.
RIGHT NOW I KNOW I KNOW I FOR
SCIENCE RIGHT YEAH.
I'M GONNA WAITING UP I THINK I
WOULD HAVE WELCOMED THE GRAPHIC.
BOB THIS IS A PROPOSAL FOR
OFFICE OF FARM TO FORK TO
REQUEST FOR FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND AUTHORITY FOR BOTH FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY. TO
FUND TWO POINT FOR EXISTING
POSITIONS IN OUR OFFICE OF FARM
TO FORK. TO ADMINISTER A FEDERAL
FOOD INSECURITY NUTRITION
INCENTIVE CRAMPED.
THAT CDFA RECEIVED A YEAR AGO
AND TO CONTINUE OUR WORK IN
IMPLEMENTING THE CALIFORNIA
NUTRITION INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
THE FUNDING WILL SUPPORT ON THE
CALIFORNIA NUTRITION INCENTIVE
PROGRAM WHICH IS DESIGNED TO
PROMOTE FOOD ACCESS WITH A FOCUS
ON HELPING.
OUR CITIZENS REDUCE DIET
RELATED DISEASE BY INCREASING
THE AMOUNT OF FRESH PRODUCE THAT
IS IN THEIR DIET. I'M SO THAT
THIS IS I'M SOMETHING THAT CAN
HELP UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
WHERE FOOD ACCESS HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE AS WELL AS PARADES
LOCAL ECONOMIC ACTIVITY BECAUSE
IT SUPPORTS PROGRAMS FARMERS
MARKETS. TO SEE ESSAYS AND LOCAL
RETAIL STORES ON THESE RESOURCES
REALLY HAVE A A A STRONG FOCUS
ON PARTNERSHIP WITH NON PROFITS
IN THE STATE. TO INCREASE PUBLIC
EDUCATION IN THE CONSUMPTION OF
CALIFORNIA GROWN PRODUCE. AND TO
COORDINATE THOSE EFFORTS ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS I APPRECIATE
YOUR.
THAT'S PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU AND IS THERE ANY.
LA OVER DEPARTMENT FINANCE
COMMENT ON THIS.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE FIVE OR SIX.
SEEING NONE I THINK WILL I WAIT
TO.
UNTIL WE HAVE A FULLER.
.
COUNTY HERE AT THE AT AT THE
DYESS TO VOTE ON THIS ITEM. WILL
DEFER THAT UNTIL LATER IN THE
MEETING AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN.
IF THIS WILL BE MY MY FINAL ITEM
AND ONE THAT SEEMS TO HAVE A LOT
OF INTEREST BECAUSE IT IS A. NEW
PROGRAM THE FIRST OF ITS KIND IN
THE NATION.
DEALING WITH THE USE OF ANTI
MICROBIAL DRIVES AND LIVESTOCK
THIS ACTUALLY WILL BE THE FINAL
PHASE OF FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF
A LOT THAT PASSED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN SB TWENTY SEVEN. THIS
PROPOSAL REQUEST TWO MILLION SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
AUTHORITY. ELEVEN POSITIONS FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN AND
ON GOING. FOR BOTH OUR ANIMAL
HEALTH AND FOOD SAFETY SERVICES
DIVISION AND OUR INSPECTION
SERVICES DIVISION WHICH OVERSEES
OUR FEET PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM HAS RECEIVED BASE
FUNDING AT THE FIRST YEAR. ONE
MILLION THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN A
POSITIONS AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN. AS WELL AS LAST YEAR
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT HAVE POSITIONS
THESE ARE HIGHLY SPECIALIZED
POSITIONS MANY OF THEM ARE
VETERINARIANS. ANIMAL HEALTH
SPECIALISTS THIS PROPOSAL AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WILL FULLY
IMPLEMENT. SP TWENTY SEVEN.
WHICH HAD AN EFFECTIVE DATE OF
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
.
WE ARE USING THE INFORMATION
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK
THAT'S BEEN PUT IN THE THE FIRST
TWO YEARS AND MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDER. OUTREACH MEETINGS
AS WELL AS ONE ON ONE VISITS TO
ALL OF THE RETAIL FEED OUTLETS
IN THE STATE. ON AND WE'RE USING
THE INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
BEEN COLLECTING AND THAT DATA.
FOR THE REGULATIONS THAT THAT
WE ARE IN CHARGE OF PRODUCING.
WHICH IS A PROGRAM THAT REALLY
WILL PUT NEW LIMITS ON THE USE
OF ANTIBIOTIC MATERIALS AND
LIVESTOCK. PRODUCTION IN THE
STATE.
PROVIDING.
EXTENSIVE STEWARDSHIP GUIDELINES
FOR EVERY SPECIES OF FARM
ANIMALS IN THE STATE. AND REALLY
HAVING A FOCUS OF REDUCING
ANTIBIOTIC USE IN THE STATE AND
APPROVING THE STEWARDSHIP
PRACTICES OF LIVESTOCK AND MEAT
PRODUCTION ANIMALS IN THE STATE.
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS HAD BEEN REYES I CAN
WAIT FOR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE RATHER THAN JUST
PLUNGING AND WITH WHERE I THINK
YOU MIGHT WANNA GO. ON THIS
TOPIC BUT I WILL SAY WE'VE BEEN
DOING EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER OUT
REACH THIS ALSO REQUIRES A GREAT
DEAL COORDINATION FOR US WITH
OUR SISTER AGENCIES. THE BOARD
OF PHARMACY AS WELL AS THE BOARD
OF VETERINARY MEDICINE.
AND SO.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
COORDINATION AND THERE WILL BE A
LOT MORE AS WE IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM TO MAKE IT AS EFFECTIVE
AS WE KNOW THAT.
IT NEEDS TO BE AND THAT WE WANT
IT TO BE AS A MODEL PROGRAM FOR
THE FOR THE COUNTRY
THANK YOU ALL HAVE AT LEAST ONE
QUESTION BUT I THINK IT MIGHT BE
USEFUL FOR US TO HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC FIRST AND THEN. I OPENED
IT UP TO QUESTIONS FROM THE DICE
IF THAT'S ALRIGHT AND.
LA HOSTS CHICKEN HAD NO SO
THERE'S NO COMMENTS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I ASSUME
THEN.
WHY DON'T WE HEAR FROM THE?
PUBLIC ON THIS ISSUE.
GOOD MORNING.
HE. IT MONNING IS THE CHAIR JUST
MULLIN ON BEHALF OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL I'M
PINCH HITTING THEM FOR THEM
TODAY WAS THEIR EXPERTS ON THE
EAST COAST. BUT I DO UNDERSTAND
THIS ISSUE AND THEY RAISE A
CONCERN THEY VERY VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF FUNDING THIS PROGRAM
THEY WERE VERY INVOLVED IN THE
STABBING XIN THIS.
THEIR CONCERN IS THE
INTERPRETATION BY THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE THEY WANT TO ENSURE THAT
BEFORE THIS FUNDING IS PROVIDED
THAT THERE IS A LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTIVE GIVEN TO. THE
DEPARTMENT
TO DO THREE THINGS.
TO ISSUE THIS GUIDANCE IN
REGULATION FORM.
SO THAT PEOPLE KNOW CLEARLY WHAT
THE PROHIBITED USES OUR.
TO COLLECT ALL VETERINARY FEED
DIRECTIVES FROM FEED MILLS AND
THIRDLY TO PUBLISH IT KLAPROTH
FOR RELIABLE DATA COLLECTION.
WE BELIEVE THEY ON THE RIGHT
PATH THEMSELVES
BUT THEY REALLY NEED TO TIGHTEN
UP SO THE PEOPLE OUGHT CLAIRE
WHAT THE STATUTE SAYS.
THE STATUTE DOESN'T INTEND TO
HAVE AS BROAD THE DESCRIPTIONS
WE BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENTS A
SINGLE.
THANK YOU.
I'M BILL ALLEY  FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
ALSO REPRESENTING.
CALPERS THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY CONSUMERS UNION CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS.
NO WE SUBMITTED INFORMATION OF A
AYE COMMITTEE AND TO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH CDFA FOR AWHILE NOW
AND FOLLOWING UP ON MR BELONGS
COMMENTS WE AGREE.
JUST FOUR MONTHS AFTER THE LAW
TOOK EFFECT THIS WAS SENATE BILL
TWENTY SEVEN THAT WE WERE
INVOLVED IN ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
WORKED HARD ON FOR A COUPLE
YEARS.
THE DEPARTMENT ISSUED GUIDANCE
WHICH WE FELT WAS A
MISINTERPRETATION OF THE LAW
THEY TOOK IT DOWN.
SINCE THEN WE'VE HAD THIS
ONGOING CONCERN THAT THEY ARE
TIGHTENING IT UP. THROUGH THE
THINGS WE ARGUED ABOUT AND
DEBATED AND CRAFTED WITH SENATOR
HOLES GUIDANCE AND OF AN
AUTHORITY. ARE TRYING TO BE
REOPENED IN THE WAY WE ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT THE FLEXIBILITY
NEEDED FOR VETERINARIAN SO WE
WANT TO SEE IT TIGHTENED DOWN SO
THAT THE INTENT. OF THE LAW IS
IMPLEMENTED THANK YOU.
MY MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS NO
KRAMERS OF CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION.
I WANT TO REITERATE A POINT THAT
SECRETARY ROSS MADE CALIFORNIA
REALLY IS A LEADER. IN.
TAKING STEPS TO EXPAND.
OVERSIGHT OF USE OF ANTIBIOTICS
WE HAVE DRAMATICALLY CHANGED THE
MANAGEMENT OF ANTIBIOTICS IN
CALIFORNIA.
NO LIVESTOCK PRODUCER CAN SIMPLY
GO AND PURCHASE ANTIBIOTICS OVER
THE COUNTER ANYMORE.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE OVERSIGHT OF A
VETERINARIAN TO USE THOSE
ANTIBIOTICS
I THINK THAT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE.
WE SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME
NEGOTIATING WITH SENATOR HELL
AND OTHERS ON. SB TWENTY SEVEN.
WE FELT IT VERY IMPORTANT THAT
VETERINARIANS MAINTAIN.
THERE
DISCRETION AS TO WHEN
ANTIBIOTICS SHOULD BE USED AND
WHEN THEY SHOULD NOT BE USED.
AND WE BELIEVE SB TWENTY SEVEN
THE LANGUAGE AND SB TWENTY
SEVEN.
LEAVES THAT DISCRETION WITH THE
VETERINARIANS IT PROVIDES
GUIDANCE IT PROHIBITS THE USE OF
ANTIBIOTICS FOR GROWTH
PROMOTION.
BUT IT DOES ALLOW THE VETS TO
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION AND CARE
FOR ANIMALS THAT NEED.
MEDICAL CARE.
WHAT?
THE OTHER FOLKS ON THAT HAVE
MEANT HAVE TESTIFIED THIS
MORNING WANT.
IS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO COME
BACK
AND MAKE CHANGES AND INSERT
ITSELF INTO THOSE MEDICAL
DECISIONS WE THINK IT'S VERY.
DANGEROUS FOR THE STATE TO BE
MAKING THOSE DECISIONS WE THINK
THAT THAT SHOULD BE LEFT TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE VETERINARIANS.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT CDF PHASE
I'M IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TWENTY
SEVEN AND WANT TO SEE THE BCP.
APPROVED AND.
CDFA HAS DONE A LOT OF WORK
THEY'VE ALREADY SURVEYED COW
CALF PRODUCERS ON ANTIBIOTIC USE
THEIR PLANNING TESTS ON SEND OUT
A SURVEY TO SHEEP PRODUCERS TO
GATHER DATA ON ANTIBIOTIC USE.
ON THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL HEALTH
AND FOOD SAFETY LAB HAS
DEVELOPED A. OF MANAGE A SYSTEM
THAT CAN THAT VETERINARIANS CAN
BRING SAMPLES AND THEY CAN TEST
WHETHER OR NOT THAT BACTERIA IS
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE ANTIBIOTICS
OR IF THERE'S RESISTANCE.
WE NEED.
MORE FUNDING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE IMPROVEMENTS AND THOSE
CHANGES CAN CONTINUE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED SO WE CAN CONTINUE
TO BE THE LEADERSHIP SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THE BCP AND
ASK THAT YOU A.
FIND THAT WITHOUT A FURTHER
DICTATING USE OF ANTIBIOTICS
THE ARAB AT IF I COULD ASK A
QUESTION.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS.
.
HOW THEN DO YOU INTERPRET?
THE LANGUAGE TREAT GUARDING CUT
OUT REGULAR PATTERN OF
ADMINISTRATION.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A
PROHIBITION ON THE REGULAR USE
CORRECT RIGHT SUPPORT SO. WHAT'S
INTERPRETATION THAT YOU ARE
ASKING IF YOU ARE USING
ANTIBIOTICS IF IF A
VETERINARIAN.
.
IS ALLOWING THE USE OF
ANTIBIOTICS.
JUST.
CONTINUALLY WITH OUT AN
IDENTIFIED HEALTH RISK THAT
WOULD BE REGULAR.
DENNIS ALBION AB HAVE THE CALVET
GRAIN FEED BECOMES BECAUSE OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
EGG FARMERS. IN THE PACIFIC EGG
AND POULTRY ASSOCIATION.
WE. ARE SB TWENTY SEVEN IS THE
MOST PROGRESSIVE AND FRANKLY
RESTRICTIVE. OF.
A BILL IN THE COUNTRY BEING
IMPLEMENTED YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR AND AND.
EIGHT EACH STEP.
BUT THERE WAS VERY CAREFUL
NEGOTIATIONS ON THIS ONE
ADMINISTRATION WITH.
THE THE PROPONENTS AND AND
OURSELVES A LIVESTOCK INDUSTRY
ON HOW THEY SHOULD BE.
A IMPLEMENTED AND AND MANAGED
AND PROVIDING ALLOWING THE VETS
TO BE ABLE TO USE THEIR. UP
MEDICAL DISCRETION ON.
WHEN AND HOW AND ABOUT IT SHOULD
BE UP PROVIDED.
IT IN FOR ANIMAL HEALTH WAS VERY
CRITICAL TO THE DISCUSSIONS AND.
UP. TO ALL SIDES INVOLVED IN SO
REVISITING THIS ISSUE NOW IN IN
IN A B. C. P..
A WE BELIEVE SHOULD BE PUT OFF.
UNTIL A UNIVERSE STATUTORY
DISCUSSION OF THAT'S WHAT THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS.
PROVISION WOULD LIKE TO DO THANK
YOU.
MY MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JUST AN OLD FIELD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO.
RECOGNIZE ON THE COMMENTS MADE
BY THE HEALTH REFORM YEAR
ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH THOSE I
DO ALSO WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
A VERY BRIEF POINTS. ONE OF
WHICH A CERTAIN WHEN I THINK OF
THE DEPARTMENT FOR WORKING
CLOSELY WITH STAKEHOLDERS I
THINK THE SECRETARY MENTIONED.
ARE THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS IT'S
NOT JUST THE LIVESTOCK INDUSTRY.
THE SAME FOLKS THERE APPEAR
TESTIFYING TODAY ARE ALSO PART
OF THAT STAKEHOLDER PROCESS FOR
THESE DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN
ONGOING AND AND ARE NOT NEW.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO REITERATE
THE FACT THAT THAT SB TWENTY
SEVEN WAS AS I MISTER ALBION HE
SAID CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED. A
THAT WAS NOT.
WINDOW DRESSING THAT WAS A
SIGNIFICANT LEFT THAT OCCURRED
AND WE'VE HAD TO HAVE SOME VERY
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS WITH
RANCHERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND THAT HAS RESULTED IN A ONE
AS MISS KRAMER'S MENTIONED.
NO ANTIBIOTICS BEING SOLD.
OR USED WITHOUT A PRESCRIPTION.
ISSUED BY A VETERINARIAN.
AND ALSO PARTICIPATION BY THE
INDUSTRY TO NOT JUST COLLECT
SALES DATA BUT ACTUAL ON FORM
USE OF ANTIBIOTICS THIS ISSUE IS
NOT ABOUT SALES THIS ISSUE IS
ABOUT COMBATING RESISTANCE.
AND WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW
RESISTANCE.
WORKS HOW THE PATTERNS TREND
AND ULTIMATELY WE ARE ENGAGED IN
DOING THAT.
.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A VESTED
INTEREST AS LIVESTOCK PRODUCERS
AND MAINTAINING THE EFFICACY OF
THESE DRUGS HAVING ANTIBIOTICS
THAT DO NOT TREAT.
ANIMAL DISEASES.
IS IS JUST AS.
A DANGEROUS FOR US AS IT IS.
FOR FOR THOSE APPEAR.
TESTIFYING AGAINST SB CP SO I
DO WANT TO SAY.
YOU KNOW WE WE SUPPORT THE B.
C. P..
AND I WOULD ASK THAT YOU.
YOU FUND IT.
WITHOUT.
WITHOUT CONDITIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MADDIE DUNLOP ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA POULTRY
FEDERATION I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
SUPPORT THIS BCP AND ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES NO LIVESTOCK
INDUSTRY.
MR TURN MEMBERS TRICIA COUNTER
WITH AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA ALSO AFFILIATING
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS OF
THE CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION AND
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU. VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF DEFACED BCP
ON IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TWENTY
SEVEN AS IT STANDS THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CRISTINA CAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CDFA REQUEST THE BCP. OF FOR THE
MOST AGGRESSIVE ANTIBIOTIC
REDUCTION OF PROGRAM IN THE
COUNTRY.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT WE
FEEL AS VETERINARIANS THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN S. B. TWENTY SEVEN
IS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR.
AND I COULD FURTHER AND JUST ONE
LAYER OF.
ADDITIONAL PROTECTION UNDER A
VETERINARY CLIENT PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP WHICH IS REQUIRED
THAT WE ARE WE ESTABLISH WITH
OUR ANIMAL PATIENTS.
IN OUR PROVISIONS IT SAYS A
DRUG SHALL NOT BE PRESCRIBED FOR
A DURATION INCONSISTENT WITH THE
MEDICAL CONDITION OF THE ANIMAL
WHERE ANIMALS WERE TYPE OF DRUG
PRESCRIBED IN SO WE ARE ALWAYS
COGNIZANT OF THE FACT.
THAT WE'RE DOING THE ANIMALS NO
GOOD IF WE OVER USE ANTIBIOTICS
FOR OUR PURPOSES IN WHICH WE'RE
NOT THINKING ABOUT THE KAREN
TREATMENT OF THE ANIMALS THINK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY AND. I WAS ALSO INVOLVED
WITH THE NEGOTIATIONS ARE ON SB
TWENTY SEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND IN.
WAS SAID BY AN EARLIER SPEAKER
THAT ASPECTS OF A SB TWENTY
SEVEN FEEL RESTRICTIVE WHILE IT
WAS MEANT TO COME YOU KNOW WE
KNOW THAT TWO MILLION AMERICANS
SUFFER FROM AND ABOUT POSSESS
INFECTIONS EVERY YEAR AND TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND DIE AND A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTOR TO THIS.
IS A THAT HAS BEEN THE LONG OVER
USE I'M OF ANTIBIOTICS IN THE
INDUSTRY THE LIVESTOCK INDUSTRY
AND WHILE WE ARE SUPER
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT INITIATIVE
HERE AND RECOGNIZE PROGRESS THAT
THE INDUSTRY IS ATTEMPTING TO BE
MADE. THAT THERE IS A FOR
THERE'S A FOCUSED SET OF
CONCERNS THAT THAT HAVE BEEN
CONVEYED TO YOU AND EXPRESS
QUITE WELL ON THE STAFF COMMENTS
THAT THERE IS A NEED TO TRUE UP
BEFORE CONTINUING TO INVEST IN
THIS PROGRAM KIND OF TRUE UP
THIS. OUTSTANDING QUESTION MARK
THAT FOLKS HAVE ABOUT
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION IN FACT
HEARING CDNAS OWN LANGUAGES
SOMETHING THAT HELPS TO DRAW A
CONNECTION INTO THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION AND HOW CDFA IS IS
REGULATING THAT'S TO MAKE SURE.
ALL STAKEHOLDERS FEEL CONFIDENT
THAT THE PROGRAM IS ROLLING OUT
THE WAY IT WAS NEGOTIATED THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AARON ALRIGHT ON BEHALF
OF BEARING YOUR INGELHEIM AND
INTO INTEREST OF TIME ISN'T FROM
THE LAST ONE I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT WILL ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS
WITH THOSE BUT FOR US. IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE BEGIN.
THANK YOU SO ON MS ROSS THEM.
BUT DID YOU WANT TO ADD SOME
COMMENTS AND PERHAPS A IN DOING
SO THERE ARE THERE ARE A COUPLE
COMMENTS ONE.
I MENTIONED AT THE VERY END OF
MY TESTIMONY THAT THIS REQUIRES
A GREAT DEAL OF COORDINATION.
WITH THOSE ENTITIES THAT HAVE
AUTHORITIES WHERE WHERE THE
AUTHORITIES ARE AND ONE IS THE
VETERINARY MEDICINE PORT. WHICH
IS WHERE THE CREDENTIALING AND
THE ON GOING LICENSING OF THAT
MARION'S HAPPENS AND WHERE THEY
HAVE THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR
GUIDANCE ON THAT. AS WELL AS THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY'S I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
WE'RE NOT THE ONLY PLAYER THIS
IS WELL COORDINATED. OUR STATE
VETERINARIAN ON HAS SOME IDEAS
ON HOW TO PROVIDE SOME CLARITY
ON GUIDANCE WITHOUT GETTING INTO
THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY THAT
OVERSEES VETERINARIANS WE DO
NOT.
HAVE THAT BUT.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS WE HAVE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS BUILT. I ALSO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WHILE YOU
HEARD FROM THE RANCHING
COMMUNITY.
THE POULTRY FEDERATION OF OTHER
LIVESTOCK PRODUCERS.
ACCESS WAS VERY IMPORTANT IN THE
DISCUSSIONS HERE THAT'S ANOTHER
BALANCING THAT WERE REQUIRED TO
MAKE. WE HAVE DIED LIKE YOU MEAN
ACCESS FOR THE ANTIBIOTICS WHEN
THEY ARE NECESSARY AND WHERE
THERE ARE VERY RULED REMOTE
AREAS. BUT ALSO IMPORTANTLY
THINKING ABOUT ALL THE LIVESTOCK
PRODUCERS IN THE STATE WHICH
INCLUDE YOUTH WHO ARE AND AFFECT
THEY ARE FOR EACH PROGRAMS
MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE ALSO
GETTING THE INFORMATION AND THAT
THEY HAVE ACCESS AND UNDERSTAND
THEY NOW HAVE TO HAPPEN
ESTABLISHED. THAT MARRIED
RELATIONSHIP FOR THE CARE OF
THEIR ANIMALS AND FOR THE
LITERALLY THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
VERY SMALL.
IT'S EASY TO CALL THEM HOBBY
FARMERS BUT THEY HAVE WEEKEND
SPRATT'S THEY MIGHT HAVE A HERD
OF TEN OR LAST.
AND THAT.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ISSUES OF
REACHING ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE IN
ADDITION TO ALL OF THOSE THAT
ARE PART.
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION OF
LIVESTOCK.
AND I JUST BOTH OF THE BALANCING
THINGS THAT WERE REQUIRED TO DO
HERE AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR YOU TO BE AWARE OF JUST HOW
FAR REACHING THIS PROGRAM DOES
THE DEPARTMENT HAVE AN
INTERPRETATION OF.
.
OF WHAT.
IT MEANS TO AT MINISTER IN A
REGULAR PATTERN.
ITS ARE CLICK ON AN AREA THAT
SHE THERE'S DOCTOR JONES.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING.
SO THE REASON THAT.
THERE'S LOTS OF PEOPLE THAT CAN
UP LOTS OF WAYS YOU COULD.
INTERPRET RECORD REGULAR
PATTERN OF USE
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING TO
REMEMBER IS THAT.
WHEN YOU'RE PRACTICING MEDICINE
WHAT YOU NEED TO CONSIDER IS THE
SPECIFIC ANIMAL ON THE SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCE IN THE PACIFIC
SPECIFIC PATHOGEN THE IMMUNE
STATUS.
AND YOU KNOW AS HUMANS WE
PROBABLY ALL BEEN TO OUR DOCTORS
SO WE CAN APPRECIATE THAT.
IN ALL MY.
MEDICAL COLLEAGUES IN THE HUMAN
MEDICINE FEEL WOULD PROBABLY.
FEEL THE SAME WAY THAT THEY NEED
THE ABILITY TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
ALL OF THOSE VARIABLES WHEN THEY
HAVE TO MAKE A MEDICAL
DETERMINATION ABOUT THE BEST
COURSE OF PRACTICE.
SO.
WHEN YOU ASK WHAT THEY HAVE IS
NOT JUST A QUICK ANSWER SO THE
WAY WERE THAT THE WAY WE'RE
INTENDING TO ANSWER IT. IS
THROUGH OUR AND STEWARDSHIP AND
YOU JUST ISSUES PRINCIPLES WHICH
WE'RE WORKING ON RIGHT NOW THAT
WILL BE MORE SPECIES SPECIFIC SO
THAT OR PRODUCTION TYPE SPECIFIC
SO THAT WE CAN PUT THOSE
GUIDELINES.
AND.
PARAMETERS TO CONSIDER IN THEIR
IN AGAIN WERE REALLY JUST
TALKING ABOUT PREVENTATIVE USE
SO.
.
THAT'S A THAT'S A MINOR.
THAT'S.
WITH DUKE DID YOU DISHES YOU
SINCE STORESHIP PREVENTED IT USE
WOULD BE A VERY VERY MINOR. PART
OF THE PRACTICE OF VETERINARY
MEDICINE OR ANY KIND OF
MEDICINE.
I TAKE YOUR POINT.
BUT AT SOME POINT THERE MAY
STILL BE A NEED TO.
INTERPRET WHAT IS MEANT BY
ADMINISTERING A MEDICALLY
IMPORTANT. DRUG IN A REGULAR
PATTERN HE.
INTERACT AND YOU'RE RIGHT I WAS
NOT CLEAR ON THAT THAT'S MY
QUESTION OKAY HIZO DO YOU HAVE A
POLICY ON THAT OR IS THERE. SAID
WHERE WHERE WHERE IS THE
DEPARTMENT ON THAT SO OUR INTENT
IS TO END QUOTE INCORPORATED
CORPORATE THAT INFORMATION INTO
OUR STEWARDSHIP OUR SPECIES ARE
PRODUCTION TYPE SPECIFIC
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS.
SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THOSE
TOOLS TO HELP BUT CANARIANS MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS AND ALSO TO
HELP.
PRODUCERS HAVE INFORMATION SO
THAT THEY CAN BE THE SAME
INFORMATION SO THAT THEY WON'T
BE MAKING YOU KNOW. REQUEST THAT
PROPS ARE INAPPROPRIATE DOES THE
DEPARTMENT SEE IT AT UNDER A
UNDER THE STATUTORY SCHEME OF
THOSE PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE
TO THE DEPARTMENT SEE IT AS. ITS
RESPONSIBILITY TO OVERSEE AND
AND FORCE.
.
ON ON THAT ISSUE SO I THINK I'M
GOING TO GET AT THE HEART OF THE
MATTER THAT'S RAISED BY TWO
SITES AND I. TAKE IT THAT THERE
IS A. CHASM BETWEEN THE TWO
SIDES THAT AND.
AND MOST SIDES FEEL THAT.
THERE INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW
IS QUITE CLEAR. YEAH ACTUALLY I
DON'T I WOULD.
RESPECTFULLY SAY I DON'T THINK
THERE IS A CHASM WERE USING
DIFFERENT WORDS BUT I THINK
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA MOVE IN THE
SAME DIRECTION.
SO I THINK AS YOU SEE THIS
PROGRAM MATURE AND WE HAVE A
REPORT THAT WILL BE YOU KNOW DO
THE LEGISLATURE NEXT YEAR. SO
YOU SHOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE GRABS NOT RATHER THAN
THAN.
YOU KNOW.
REF OFF OF MY USE OF OF
LANGUAGE.
LET'S FOCUS ON THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S ACTUALLY IN DISPUTE MAYBE
IT'S NOT A CHASM MAYBE IT'S A
VERY NUANCED DIFFERENCE WHATEVER
IT IS THERE'S A DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION AND MY QUESTION.
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSTAND
IF IF THERE'S AN ANSWER TO IS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THE DEPARTMENT.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME HAS A
PLAN TO ADMINISTER THAT
PARTICULAR.
AND AND AND AND DO SOME
ENFORCEMENT IF ENFORCEMENT WERE
TO BE NECESSARY BECAUSE I. I I I
I I HEAR THE AGRICULTURE SIDE OF
FOR THIS DEBATE SAYING LEAVE IT
TO THE.
THAT TO THE VETERINARIAN TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION JUST LIKE
IF I WERE TO GO TO MY PHYSICIAN
AND THE PHYSICIAN SAYS YOU NEED
AN ANTIBIOTIC.
WE'RE LEAVING IT TO THAT
POSITION HOWEVER.
.
HUMAN DOCTORS AS YOU AS YOU PUT
IT DON'T HAVE A STATUTE THAT
SAYS.
GET TO A AT A REGULAR PATTERN.
LEAST SWORDS I'M AWARE. OF.
AND SO WHETHER IT'S RIGHT OR
WRONG THE LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED
A LAW THAT IT CURES TO. A DROP
IN YOUR LAP.
AYE A OVERSIGHT ENFORCEMENT
ISSUE WHEN.
MS ROSS YOU LOOK LIKE YOU ARE
JOB BUT I JUST WANNA SAY THAT
PART OF OUR VISITORS ITEM OPEN
BY THE WAY ASTRONAUT YEAH
HIGHER.
IT'S A THEORY WHERE YOU ARE
DISCUSSION AND WE WILL BE
ENGAGED IN THIS WITH OLIVER
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE IMPLEMENT THE
SLOT.
BUT THE COLLECTION OF THE DATA.
AND THOSE USE PATTERNS WILL HELP
US THAT'S WHAT WE'RE COLLECTING
NOW THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO
INFORM THE STEWARDSHIP
GUIDELINES THAT WILL DEFINE FOR
US SO THAT WE CAN SEE WHERE THE
OUT WIRES ARE AND IDENTIFY. WHAT
DOES SEEM TO BE A GLARING
REGULAR USE THAT CALLS INTO
QUESTION?
BUT I ALSO HAVE TO KEEP POINTING
OUT THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY OVER THE
VETERINARIANS THEMSELVES THIS
DATA ITS COORDINATION WITH THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD. THAT
OVERSEES AND THEY ARE GOING TO
BE REQUIRED FOR NEW EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH TO VETERINARIANS IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S ALL
WORKING TOGETHER. WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY OVER WHAT'S BEING SOLD
IN THE FEET STORES THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY HAS AUTHORITY OVER
THOSE THAT ARE GOING TO GO
THROUGH AND GET A RETAIL LICENSE
TO BE ABLE TO BE A PHARMACY FOR
DISPENSING THESE PRODUCTS. THESE
ARE ALL THINGS THAT REQUIRE US
ALL TO WORK CLOSELY TOGETHER BUT
THIS IMPLEMENTATION PHASE THAT
WERE IN IS ALSO ABOUT COLLECTING
THE DATA.
TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUALLY AND
FORM THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AND
TO KNOW WHERE THAT OUT LIARS ARE
AND WHAT IS WHAT IS CREATING.
THE PROBLEMS AND ADDRESS THEM
VERY SPECIFICALLY I.
THEY'VE THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I
WAS GONNA SAY IS THE THE
ENFORCEMENT THAT YOU'RE ASKING
ABOUT IS TO THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD AND WE HAVE.
YEAH XIN SHIP WITH THEM AND THE
LAN FACT.
ALLOWS US TO PROVIDE SOME
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION TO THEM
IT HAS A PROVISION TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT SO THAT WOULD BE THE
ALBANY FOR ENFORCEMENT. OKAY
WELL OF LOT MORE TO DISCUSS I
APPRECIATE THAT. THE THE
FEEDBACK GUY MISTER MULLIN
STRONG.
THANK YOU AS CHAIR AND THANK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOR THE
DISCUSSION.
WHEN I HEAR THE PHRASE IMMUNE
STATUS I KNOW THAT THIS MUCH OF
THIS CONVERSATIONS PROBABLY
ABOVE MY PAY GRADE HERE.
BUT I DID CARRIED SOME
LEGISLATION ON.
ANTIBIOTIC USE
ULTIMATELY A SENATOR HILLS BILL
NOT PREVAILED. THAT'S NOW THE
STATE LAW YEAH I'D LIKE TO SEE
THAT IMPLEMENTED I KNOW THERE'S
LOTS OF CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING
IN THAT REGARD IT.
I GUESS. AFTER HEARING PUBLIC
COMMENT AND AND THE EXCHANGE AIP
I PROBABLY NEED A LITTLE MORE
CLARITY.
THIS GOING FOR IT I SUSPECT AT
ALL SUPPORT ULTIMATELY SUPPORT
THE ITEM.
AND I THINK I HEARD IN THERE
SOMEWHERE THAT SOME ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE WILL BE.
PROVIDED BUT
MAYBE BABY FROM THAT DIRECTOR
IF YOU IF YOU COULD MAYBE JUST
KINDA AMPLIFY THAT POINT AGAINST
THE THOSE CONCERNED WITH THIS.
ARE REALLY SEIZING ON THIS ISSUE
AROUND.
PREVENTIVE YOU SEND SOME
ADDITIONAL GUIDELINES SO OR
GUIDANCE ARE SO.
IT'S DEPARTMENT COMMITTING TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE
AS PART OF THIS STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATION AND YET GOING YEAH.
YES ABSOLUTELY THAT'S THAT'S
PART OF THE DISCUSSION MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE STAYING AT THAT
OUR STATUTORY AUTHORITY. THAT WE
CAN DO IT IN A WAY THAT'S NOT.
.
PRESCRIBING.
ABOUT A VETERINARIAN SHOULD BE
DOING I MEAN THERE ARE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS ARE SCIENCE
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE ABOUT
HALF REQUIREMENTS FOR THE ON
GOING LICENSING. BUT YES WORK
WE'RE COMMITTED TO DOING THIS
BASED ON DATA BASE ON SCIENCE
AND BASED ON PUTTING TOGETHER
THE STEWARDSHIP GUIDELINES THIS
IS ABOUT AND AND I HOPE THAT I I
THOUGHT IT CAME THROUGH FOR THE
LIVESTOCK SECTOR.
THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCERS HAVE
MADE A COMMITMENT TO DO
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT BEING
REQUIRED IN OTHER PLACES AND
THEY'RE VERY SINCERE AND THAT
COMMITMENT BUT IT IS. IT IS
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE.
WITH THE RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
VETERINARIAN OF SOME OF THE
SMALL FARMERS THAT MAY NOT HAVE
AN ON GOING THAT IN A
RELATIONSHIP. ON AND SO WE'RE
VERY COMMITTED TO DOING THAT AND
I ALSO HAVE TO SAY. THE FOCUS ON
COMING UP WITH GUIDELINES FOR
YOUTH WITH THEIR YOUTH PROJECTS
ALSO CREATES A NEW GENERATION
THAT'S AWARE OF SOMETHING THAT.
THAT TRADITIONAL PRODUCERS.
WE DIDN'T HAVE BEFORE THEM THAT
TWENTY YEARS AGO SO I THINK
WE'RE VERY COMMITTED TO DOING
THAT WHETHER I'M SECRETARY OR
NOT OUR PROFESSIONAL STAFF IS
VERY COMMITTED TO THE S. AND I
WILL SAY. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BRING ON SOME OUTSTANDING NEW
VETERINARIANS AS WELL AS ANIMAL
HEALTH PRACTITIONERS THAT.
ART THEORY FOCUSED ON DOING
THIS AND DOING IT THE RIGHT WAY.
AND THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT YOU
ANTICIPATE HAPPENING. ARE
HAPPENING HERE BUT THEY'RE NOT
REALLY HAPPENING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY REDDING CALIFORNIA IT
LEVEL LEADING THIS CONVERSATION
NATIONAL YEAH AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
THROUGH.
THROUGH AT ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REQUIRED THAT NIGHT FEET
DIRECTIVES. THAT THAT DEAL WITH
THE AVAILABILITY OF ANTIBIOTICS
BUT NOT IN STATURE STATUTE THE
WAY THAT WE ARE. ON THERE'S
COLLECTION OF DATA BUT NOT TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE ARE. A
MINISTERIAL PORTENT TO REMEMBER
THAT AS A PRODUCTION STATE EVEN
WITH THE LIKES OF POPULATION
NUMBERS WE HAVE. WE STILL BRING
A LOT OF OUR MEAT PRODUCTS FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SO WHERE
ADDRESSING SOMETHING IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT IT'S IT AND I THINK IT WILL
HAVE INFLUENCE BUT IT'S ALSO
BEAT TO BE MINDFUL THAT A LOT OF
OUR MEAT PRODUCTS PROTEIN
PRODUCTS TO COME FROM OTHER
STATES AND OTHER COUNTRIES.
WELL FROM A LEGAL PERSPECTIVE
IT'S A FASCINATING ISSUE IT
MOUNTED IT US BUT YOU'RE ALSO
INTO CHAT ACT COME OVER ANY TIME
OR I'LL COME OVER WITH OUR STAFF
TO GET INTO THIS MORE DETAIL IF
YOU'D LIKE TO. THAT WOULD BE
GREAT TO.
I'M SURE WILL. HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSIDER IT IN
MORE DEPTH.
AS SOON.
A AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS I'D.
I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE
INTENT OF THE LAW AND I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE.
INDUSTRY IS STEPPING UP AND
TAKING ACTION ON AN ISSUE THAT
REALLY DOES AFFECT POURTANT TO.
.
IT HAPPENS SOMETIMES THAT OTHERS
AMBIGUITIES AND OTHER LAWS THAT
WE DRAFT AND.
THAT'S BEEN DROPPED IN YOUR LAP
MS ROSS OF AND I CAN SENSE OF
THE FACT THAT IT'S CREATED SOME
INTERNAL TENSION. OF BUT OF ITS
WILL TRY TRY TO WORK WITH YOU TO
SEE IF WE CAN'T RESOLVE IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TO WORK
ON THE WHOLE THAT ITE OPEN AND.
.
RIGHT. YES AND THAT. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE ON TO.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY.
MR INJURY AS YOU'VE BEEN COOLING
THEIR HEELS FOR AWHILE.
I.
RIGHT. WELL IMAGINE THE ALARMED
THAT WAS UNSETTLING. KNOWN NOW
IT WAS I WAS OUT OF THE OFFICE
YESTERDAY AND AND GOT A LITTLE
BIT OVER AMBITIOUS AND MY
QUESTIONING OF THE STAFF THIS
MORNING SEVERAL.
AND THOUGHT WE COULD MAKE IT UP
BY RUNNING OVER HERE BUT THE.
I OVERESTIMATE MY ABILITY TO
RUN THESE DAYS HIGH I THINK.
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING WELL
ACTUALLY THERE'S SOME PEOPLE WHO
GET A LOT OF REGULAR EXERCISE
HERE I'M NOT ALWAYS ONE OF THEM.
BUT IF I.
CAUSE YOU TO RUN OVER TO GET A
LITTLE EXERCISE I'M NOT GONNA.
NOT GONNA FEEL BAD ABOUT THAT
NOW IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S A GOOD
LESSON FOR ME IN MANY WAYS AND
THE ALSO IS VERY INSTRUCTIVE TO
HEAR THE LAST OF THE OUTSIDE OF
A. A DISCUSSION SO I I I
BENEFITED FROM THEM WELL GOT A
GOOD MORNING WE KEPT YOU
WAITING.
ALL THIS TIME HERE ONE ISSUE
AND.
AND IT'S SMALL GRANTS SO
PERHAPS EVEN A SMALL I'M SURE
THESE ARE SMALL GRANTS OF BIG
IMPACT THOUGH SO WHEN IT YOU
JUST LAUNCH INTO YOUR.
A DISCUSSION OF.
ISSUE ONE HOW WILL THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
I HAVE.
JANA GARCIA OUR SYSTEM
SECRETARY FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE STUFF WITH ME TODAY AS
WELL AS THE ERA GRANT OR
MINISTRY TO OFFICER.
GRANT ERIK JARVIS I APOLOGIZE.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
LOVE AND LET ME BE BRIEF AND TO
THE POINT.
THAT ARE YOU HAVE WAITED THIS
LONG ANYONE A LONGER AND A
LITTLE BIT PROBABLY OKAY.
.
NOW AT ITS STILL WISE TO BE VERY
FAST SO.
LET LET ME GET RIGHT TO THE
POINT AND THAT IS THAT THAT.
OBVIOUSLY OUR BUDGET SHOWS A A
GREAT COMMITMENT TO.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW JUSTICE IN
PARTICULAR.
NOW THE AGENDA FOR TODAY
DESCRIBES OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE SMALL GRANTS.
BCP VERY ACCURATELY AND IN
PARTICULAR WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DEAL WITH AND THAT BCP IS A LACK
OF FUNDING FOR THE US SMALL
GRANTS PROGRAM. AS YOU MENTIONED
THE IT'S A A SMALL PROGRAM IN
MANY WAYS IN THE GRANTS
THEMSELVES ARE NOT VERY LARGE
BUT IT'S BEEN A VERY INFLUENTIAL
PROGRAMS THROUGH THE YEARS.
WE'VE ISSUED.
OVER A THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
GRANTS THAT SINCE THE INCEPTION
OF THE PROGRAM.
BUT THERE'S NEVER BEEN A STABLE
FUNDING SOURCE.
OUR JUNE.
TWENTY SIXTEEN VINYL JUSTICE
REPORT TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
NUMEROUS SMALL GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED BY THIS
PROGRAM. AND THIS YEAR.
WE'VE RECEIVED OVER US SEVENTY
ELIGIBLE APPLICATIONS A TOTALING
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN REQUESTED
GRANT FUNDING. AND WE HAVE A
MILLION DOLLARS TO COMMIT TO A
WARD SO. AS TODAY'S AGENDA
SUGGEST SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR IS PROVIDING FUNDING FOR
NEXT YEAR.
OUT AND.
IT'S A ONE TIME REQUESTED AT
THIS POINT.
AND WHAT WE'D BE DOING IS
REALLY TAPPING INTO SOME OF THE.
PENALTY FUNDS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AT THE THE STATE WATER
BOARD THE AIRBORNE CALORIE CYCLE
AND ID TSC.
TO FUND THE PROGRAM IN THE NEXT
YEAR.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S AN
ISSUE WITHIN THE DTS SEE BUDGET
AND SO WE'D BE MINDFUL THAT AS
WE'RE LOOKING THAT TO PROVIDE
FUNDING. OF BUT WE DO WANT TO
CONTINUE FUNDING THIS PROGRAM OF
THE AND THE BY GETTING THIS
FUNDING THAT ALLOW US TO TO
REALLY. GO AHEAD WITH THE
TRANSITION TALK TO THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATION AND TALK ABOUT
HOW THEY MIGHT WISH TO A FUND
THIS PROGRAM IN THE FUTURE.
SO THERE ARE.
IS A QUESTION THAT'S RAISED IN
THE.
STAFF COMMENTS.
.
USING SOME.
ELEGANT LANGUAGE. SAYING THAT
THAT TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL
ACCOUNT IS UNDER PRESSURE WHICH
I US SOON MEANS IT'S.
JUST ABOUT READY TO GO UPSIDE
DOWN.
AND THE THE QUESTION THAT'S
RAISED AS IF IF THAT'S THE CASE
THEN WHY RELY ON.
ON THAT FUND.
OUR HOPE WOULD BE TO GET THAT
FUND.
BACK AND TO A A PROPER BALANCE
IS THAT THERE'S A STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE IN THAT FUND.
I THINK THERE'S FUNDING THAT
WILL CARRY US THROUGH THE NEXT
YEAR AND.
BUT WE DO NEED TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE FUNDING FOR LONG TERM FOR
THAT AT A PARTICULAR ACCOUNT. SO
WE KNOW WE CAN'T RELIED IN THE
LONG TERM.
AND IF WE MAKE THE
DETERMINATION THAT THERE'S NOT
FUNDING TO TAKE OUT OF IT AND
THAT THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR THAN
WE WOULD CERTAINLY.
NOT TAKE ANY FUNDING OUT OF IT
BUT AREN'T YOU.
ADVANCING AT THE FUNDS
INSOLVENCY IF THAT'S WHERE IT'S
HEADED BY TAKING MONEY OUT NOW
THIS IS THIS IS A VERY VERY
SMALL AMOUNTS AND AS I SAID WE.
WE WOULDN'T DO ANYTHING THAT
WOULD ADVANCE THAT INSOLVENCY IN
THE LONG TERM.
OFF OR THE SHORT TERM.
WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT THE STATUS
OF THE ACCOUNT.
AND IF WE DETERMINE THAT WE
CAN'T TAKE ANY FINDING OUT OF IT
WE WOULDN'T.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY. THAT SAYS IT IS A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE.
ON THE SIDE OF.
WHEN.
WHAT?
GOOD MORNING CHUCK MOSELY
CALIFORNIA RELIEF.
COME JUST SUPPORTING THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION OF FUN AS WE
THINK IT'S AN EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE FUNDING FOR
THIS FISCAL YEAR. AS YOU SAID
MISTER CHAIR.
SMALL GRANTS BIG IMPACT.
GIVEN THAT THESE ARE FOCUSED ON
SERVING UNDER SERVED AREAS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THESE ARE
SOME OF THE MOST ACCESSIBLE
FUNDS FOR THESE AD UNDERSERVED
AREAS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WHEN
IT COMES TO STATE GRANT PROGRAMS
THE APPLICATION IN THE PROCESS.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION OR SUPPORT.
WHAT HOURS WITH PASSES THAT
ACTION NETWORKING CALIFORNIANS
FOR PESTICIDE REFORM ALSO
SUPPORT STAFF'S RECOMMENDATION
AS IT'S BEEN PREVIOUSLY STATED
THESE ARE SOME OF THE MOST
IMPACTFUL DOLLARS ON AND IN
LIGHT OF? PROBABLY DIMINISHING
FEDERAL FUNDS RUN FINAL JUSTICE
ISSUES WE THINK IT'S ALL THE
MORE IMPORTANT TO MOVE THESE.
ARE FUN FOR WE'VE SEEN THESE
FUNDS USED FOR A VARIETY OF
ISSUES IN COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
ON THE FRONT LINES OF. EXPOSURES
TO ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINANTS
AND PROVIDE VALUABLE INFORMATION
RESEARCH AND COMMUNITY OUTREACH
THAT JUST CAN'T BE DONE BY
ANYBODY ELSE.
THANK YOU.
SO WE HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROVE THIS ITEM IS BUDGETED
AND JOBS.
WE MIGHT AS WELL.
.
YOU WERE WITH US BECAUSE OUR
MOTION ON THIS ITEM.
I'LL SECOND THAT.
BLOOM.
I.
FALL.
CHOLERA.
MOHAN. PATTERSON.
IT WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN ON
NAFTA. AWAITING MR KARA'S
ARRIVAL I THINK HE'S DUE BACK
SHORTLY AND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THINK WE'VE
BEEN HERE THIS MORNING. REPORTS
SAYING AGAIN SOON.
MY PLEASURE THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR LAST
DEPARTMENT SAID TO BE HEARD FROM
TODAY DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
DIRECTOR BUT I THINK IT'S HERE
AND TO.
I GUESS WE'LL GO THROUGH ALL
THESE ITEMS AND TAKE UP PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END NOTING THAT.
I RECEIVED A LETTER. RELATING
TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE ISSUES
NUMBER NINE AND TEN.
THAT'S THE.
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM IN THE
REGULATORY FIELD INSPECTION
PROGRAM ADD THAT BASED ON THAT
LETTER WHICH WAS SIGNED BY A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF BOTH THE.
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE WILL.
HOLD THAT ITEM THOSE ITEMS OPEN.
RATHER THAN TAKING A VOTE ON
THEM TODAY.
WELCOME. CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING OF TRYING TO KEEP
THIS BRIEF AND IF YOU HAVE A
BUSY DAY.
THE FIRST SET OF BCP'S ARE
RELATED TO THE THAT A DOG A
RENEWAL PLAN TWO. THREE YEARS
AGO WHEN I CAME ON BOARD WE PUT
TOGETHER A PLAN FOR OVERHAULING.
OUR REGULATORY PERFORMANCE AND.
INCLUDED NUMEROUS ITEMS AND
ITEMS INCLUDING THAT INTO THE
BCP RELATED ARE RELATED TO THAT
ONE IS A STAFFING. FOR
ENFORCEMENT OF SIX POSITIONS.
FIELDS INSPECTIONS STOP INCREASE
OUR ABILITY TO FIELD INSPECTIONS
AT TWENTY ONE POSITIONS.
TO CONTINUE WITH THE WELL STAR
IT OVERHAUL WHICH IS. OF THE
GOOD NEWS IS IT'S ON TIME AND ON
BUDGET AND AND IN FACT IN ABOUT
A FEW WEEKS WE WILL RID RID.
IT ROLL OUT THE CORE OF THAT
NEW IT PROGRAM A STATEWIDE. AND
THE AND THE NEXT PHASE OF IT
WILL BE ROLLED OUT IN THE FALL.
AND THE LAST NAME IS BASICALLY.
A BUDGET ITEM TWO I IMPLEMENTED
A CENTER LARS BILL THAT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR. SP SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR. REGARDING DESERTED
WELLS IN OUR PROGRAM TO.
REGULATE MANAGED DESERTED WELLS.
THE DESERT WELL THING FOR
EXAMPLE WILL GIVE US THE ABILITY
TO MORE AND MORE UNIFORM. AWAY
IN A SYSTEMATIC WAY TO REMEDIATE
THE LARGE NUMBERS OF DESERT
WELLS AND FACILITIES IN THE
STATE.
WITH REGARD THE ENFORCEMENT BC
HE WILL ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE
ENFORCEMENT UNIT. WE BELIEVE ARE
PROBABLY IF NOT THE ONLY ONE OF
ONLY VERY FEW STATE AGENCIES
THAT DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE A
DEDICATED ENFORCEMENT UNIT. OF
THIS WILL GIVE US SIX POSITIONS
FOR THAT A CORE TEAM TO ENFORCE
VIOLATIONS ACROSS THE STATE. OF
THE OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
WELLS THAT WE REGULATE.
IT ALSO GIVES US EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY IS THE CAPACITY TO
VERIFY COMPLIANCE WHEN
VIOLATIONS ARE ISSUED AND THAT'S
FOR. A FIELD INSPECTORS TO THE
B. C. B. INCLUDES TWENTY ONE TO
THE. NEW FIELD INSPECTORS. WE
COMPARED OUR CURRENT STATUS WITH
OTHER OIL PRODUCING STATES AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVE FEWER ON
AVERAGE PER WELLS AND. A FEW
INSPECTORS.
AND THIS WOULD ACTUALLY BRING US
ALL MORE CONSISTENT ALLOW US TO
MOVE MORE COMPLETELY. OUR
REVIEW.
SITES WHERE THERE HAVE BEEN
VIOLATIONS.
.
IN ADDITION.
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE WHEN I JUST
ASKING FOR POSITIONS THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS GOING ON TO
IMPROVE OUR ABILITY TO DO
INSPECTIONS. ARE THIS INCLUDES A
CENTRALIZED DISPATCHING SYSTEM
BEFORE WE I CAME ON I WAS KIND
OF A RANDOM ACTIVITY WHEN YOU
DIDN'T INSPECTION NOT
NECESSARILY PRIORITIZING. WE NOW
PUT GPS DEVICES ON OUR ALL OF
OUR FUEL VEHICLES WE DISPATCHED
TO THE NEXT OFFICIAL WHERE WE
CAN SO WE ACTUALLY GET PRIORITY
SITES. AS EFFICIENTLY WE CAN
WHETHER IT BE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WORN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES
WHERE A TRAFFIC ISSUES ARE VERY
CHALLENGING TO GET OUT TO SITES.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN WE'RE EXPLORING
A COUPLE OTHER THINGS ONE IS TO
DO. RIGHT REMOTE ARE WITNESSING
OF TESTS ARE USING A GEO CODED
VIDEO CONFERENCING THIS IS
SOMETHING WE'RE EXPLORING AND IN
THE FUTURE WHICH WOULD MAKE OUR
WORK MORE EFFICIENTLY.
TO.
FOR SOME TYPES OF TESTS. ARM.
ON THIS SIDE AND WE'RE VERY
WE'RE COUPLE WITH LA
RECOMMENDATION THAT THIS ITEM
THAT WE BASICALLY.
WILL REPORT BACK ON THIS AND IN
THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
THE LAST ITEM AS I MENTIONED WAS
THE I. T. PROGRAM. AGAIN IT'S
GOING VERY WELL THIS IS A
FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR ABILITY TO
REGULATE OIL AND GAS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE ON A
VERY ARCHAIC SYSTEM ACTUALLY A
SYSTEM WEIGHT WEIGHT BEHIND
OTHER STATES.
THIS SYSTEM HAS BEEN. THE GOOD
NEWS IS FOR A MAJOR IT PROJECT
LIKE THIS AND I WOULD BASICALLY
FROM START TO FINISH. I WILL
HAVE IN PLACE WITHIN THREE
YEARS.
WE'RE NOW AT THE. LIKE I SAID IN
A FEW WEEKS WERE ACTUALLY
ROLLING OUT THE CORE OF IT.
THAT IT SYSTEM BY THE WAY
INVOLVES WE'VE BEEN DOING
TRAINING WORKSHOPS WITH
OPERATORS AND THE INDUSTRY
BECAUSE IT'S AS MUCH THEIR TOOLS
AS OURS. ARE SO WE'VE BEEN DOING
ACTIVELY TRAININGS FOR INDUSTRY
BOTH.
OPERATORS AND OUR DEPARTMENT
ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
AND THEN THE LAST ITEM.
LEE IS A. WE'RE DRESSED ARE
REQUESTING A REALLY SMALL
FINDING SUPPORT FOR TSUNAMI
HAZARDS MAPPING THIS IS A WE'RE
KINDA CALIFORNIA AS THE STATE OF
THE ART STAY THE OUR EFFORT IN
DOING THIS WHERE WE. LOOK AT
COASTAL COMMUNITIESAND PROJECT
WHEN THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT
SIZE POTENTIAL TSUNAMIS. WHERE
WHAT COMMUNITIES AND WHAT PART
OF THE NEIGHBORHOODS WOULD
ACTUALLY IMPACTED THIS IT'S BEEN
DONE IN A FEW US SEVERAL
COMMUNITIES ALONG THE COAST?
THIS HAPPENING I WILL ALLOW US
TO COMPLETE THAT.
DOWN THE COAST AS A TOOL FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PLAN FOR
DISASTER. SO WITH THAT ALLAH
WILL STOP AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS WITH ME I HAVE.
I HAVE BEEN TURNER LEGISLATIVE
DEPUTY ALSO HAVE OUR ADMIN
DIRECTOR HERE IN THE AUDIENCE.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS
POINT MISTER PAUL.
I JUST. ONE QUICK QUESTION MAYBE
THE THE THE NAVY CAN CAN
ELABORATE CERTAINLY THE
OPERATIONS OF YOUR.
DEPARTMENT HAVE A VERY LARGE
IMPACT IN MY DISTRICT IN KERN
COUNTY AND I APPRECIATE THE THE
FEEDBACK AND AND AND AND THE AND
THE ACCESS TO YOUR STAFF IN
TERMS OF GETTING INFORMATION.
CERTAINLY THERE IS A SIDE ISSUE
THAT'S NOT RELATED TO THIS WHICH
IS. THE THE CURRENT BACKLOG IN
pYOU COULD JUST PROVIDE A LATE
THAT AN UPDATE UNSURE WHAT THE
CURRENT QUOTE CURRENT STATUS IS.
SO THAT I MEAN I KNOW AS WE
COMMUNICATED IS JUST MAYBE. IT'S
SO THAT WOULD
SOME CONFUSION AND THERE'S ONE
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ALL
OPERATING OFF THE SAME DATA AND
INFORMATION SO YOU KNOW HOW MANY
TOTAL PERMITS ARE THERE
CURRENTLY BEING REVIEWED. WHILE
THAT IF YOU CAN JUST PROVIDE ME
WITH THAT INFORMATION OKAY SO.
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF FRAME ON
THAT SO AND WE'VE HAD THE BACK
AS YOU KNOW FROM NEVER
LEGISLATORS CONCERNED THAT WE
HAVE WE'RE TATE WORSE BEING
FEARLESS WHAT SLOWER THAN WE'VE
BEEN IN THE PAST. FOR ISSUING
NEW PERMITS FOR FOR DRILLING AND
YOU PROJECT PERMITS ARM. IS JUST
POLITICAL WITH THAT PERSPECTIVE
THREE YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
WAS CONCERNED WE WERE ISSUING
PERMITS WAY TOO FAST WITH AN
ADEQUATE REVIEW.
A NUMBER OF LEGISLATION FOR PAST
OR. IN IN ADDITION THAT WE'RE
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE U. S.
EPA FOR LACK OF A PROPER REVIEW.
SO WITH THESE NEW REQUIREMENTS
WE'RE STEPPING UP OUR SCIENCE IN
TERMS OF REVIEWING NEW.
INJECTION PROJECTS FOR VIEWING.
WELL PERMITS THAT ADDITIONAL
SCIENCE DOES TAKE MORE TIME.
IN ADDITION THE
THE LEGISLATURE IS VAST AND AND.
.
WE NOW HAVE A LARGE MUCH BIGGER
ROLE THE WATER BOARD TO DO A
SIMILAR MORE THOROUGH REVIEWS SO
THAT REVIEW COMES TO US ECHOES
THE WATER BOARD. IS SO THAT SO
THAT JUST INHERENTLY IS GONNA
HAVE MORE TIME TO PROCESS AND
THIRD. EYE IS THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT.
AND I SAY NO THERE BUT THEY'RE
BUMPS AND INEFFICIENCIES THAT
ARE MAKING THIS PROCESS EVEN
LONGER THAN IT PROBABLY NEEDS TO
BE. I EVEN WITH THOSE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS BUT ONE OF THOSE IS
IS THAT WITH THIS NEWS ENDEP
SCIENCE EVALUATION. IT'S
REQUIRING THAT WE GET A DAY.
INFORMATION AND ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM THE INDUSTRY.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE THE
FRUSTRATIONS WITH INDUSTRY IS AS
IT GOES THROUGH THE PROCESS THEY
GET ADDITIONAL REQUESTS FOR
INFORMATION. SO WE'VE TAKEN
SEVERAL STEPS TO TRY AND MAKE
THIS MORE TRANSPARENT. ARE MORE
STRAIGHT FORWARD AND TO
ELIMINATE.
ANY INEFFICIENCIES AND MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A THOROUGH SCIENTIFIC
REVIEW.
WITHOUT EXTENDING THE PROCESS
EVEN MORE WE NEED TO. ONE OF
THOSE IS WE. HAVE PUT TOGETHER
AN ANIMAL YOU WITH THE WATER
BOARD SET WE IT'S VERY CLEAR.
HOW WE RELATE TO THEM HOW WE
SHARE INFORMATION ETCETERA?
THE SECOND IS WE PUT TOGETHER
KIND OF A VERY CLEAR A CHECKLIST
OF WHAT IS ALL THE SCIENTIFIC
INFORMATION THAT THE OPERATORS
NEED TO SUBMIT SO THEY KNOW UP
FRONT AND HOPEFULLY MOST ALL OF
IT COMES IN AT THE VERY
BEGINNING. AND THEY'RE NOT YOU
KNOW THE PROCESS ISN'T BEING
DELAYED FOR THAT INFORMATION SO
FOR EXAMPLE OF ALL THE
OUTSTANDING PERMITS RIGHT NOW.
ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT OF THOSE
HAVE BEEN HELD UP. I DO TOO
WAITING FOR INFORMATION THAT WE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION REQUESTED
FROM THE OPERATORS.
THE THE OTHER THINGS WE'VE DONE
IS WE'VE CREATED IN IN THIS
FRANKLY THIS IS DUE TO A LOT OF
THE YOU KNOW THE INPUT FROM THE
LEGISLATORS HERE WE'VE HAD A
COUPLE OF.
.
RICHARD COULD MEETINGS IS THE
WORD I'D USE BUT COULD MEET AT
YOUR CONSTRUCTIVE MEETINGS AND
ONE OF THOSE IS KIND OF A SIDE
ISSUE OF LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
WHERE ARE THINGS THE PROCESS YOU
KNOW AND FRANKLY THAT MIGHT LEAD
TO SOME DELAYS. WITHOUT WE'VE
NOW CREATED ONLINE BOTH US AND
THE WATER BOARD IS A DASHBOARD
WHERE YOU CAN TRACK THE STATUS
OF THESE PERMITS AND WE'VE DONE
THAT SENSE. MEETING WITH
LEGISLATORS A FEW WEEKS AGO.
I AM SO THERE'S ALL THESE THINGS
AND AND AND.
IT'S THE SAME TIME WE RECOGNIZE
REALLY THERE IS THERE IS. EFFORT
TAKING INCREASE EFFICIENCY
HANDLE THESE THINGS FASTER AND
AND MOVING FOR NOT UNNECESSARILY
CAUSE DELAYS BUT I THINK THERE
THERE WILL IT'S NOT. AND I THINK
SOME FOLKS IS NOT IF IT IS A
SOUND LIKE YOU RECOGNIZE IT AS A
COMPLETE SEPARATE ISSUE FROM THE
ISSUE OF ENFORCEMENT. AND
COMPLIANCE INSPECTORS.
BUT IT'S IN IT IN THIS CASE
IT'S NOT SO MUCH AN ISSUE OF
STAFFING.
THE PRIMARY ISSUE IS THESE THESE
INITIAL SIGNS OF REQUIREMENTS
THE DISH OF STEPS THE PROCESS
AND I WILL SAY SOME LACK OF.
OF COORDINATION US SO THAT
PROCESS AND PEOPLE KNOW WHERE
THINGS ARE SO THEY CAN BIRD DOG
AT THE RIGHT PLACE. SO THAT'S
WHERE THINGS ARE AT I. TERMS THE
ACTUAL NUMBERS ON.
BEN TURNER CAN GIVE IT WHERE
THINGS ARE SO THE THERE ARE A.
ABOUT EIGHTY SIX PENDING YOU I
SEE.
PROJECT PERMITS.
IN THOSE CORRESPOND ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED INJECTORS I'M NOT
EXACTLY SURE HOW MANY PRODUCERS.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT WE DON'T
EVALUATE THAT NECESSARILY WITH
YOU I SEE PROJECT UNTIL WE COULD
GET AN ALLY ON THAT.
SO I APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE OUR
WORK IN AND CERTAINLY THAT I
THINK THAT THE CHALLENGE FOR US
IS. IS THAT WHILE YOU'RE WHERE
YOU'RE ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDS IT'S JUST THAT THERE'S
THERE'S A.
THE BAILIFF IN THE ROOM IN TERMS
OF OF WHAT OUR PRIORITIZING SO
JUST LIKE THAT CLEARS EIGHTY SIX
PENDING YOU I SEE.
PERMITS AND EIGHTY HUNT AND
THAT INVOLVES EIGHT HUNDRED
WELLS. GIVE OR TAKE A HUNDRED
EJECTORS I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE
HOW MANY PRODUCERS DOES
CORRESPOND TO. THINK ABOUT MORE
THAN EIGHT HUNDRED APPRECIATE
THAT.
THIS CRAP. UP I'M GONNA FORGO MY
QUEST A BIG. BREAK FOR. ABOUT
FOUR GOT MY QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW
BUT I UNDERSTAND HOLDING OVER WE
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
SOME ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BEFORE
WE VOTE WE ARE UPHOLDING THIS
OPEN AND IT WILL COME BACK TO US
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE A MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO BE.
AROUND THE SET OKAY THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT.
OH I'M SORRY MR MALL AND YOU HAD
A QUESTION.
WAIT TILL.
OKAY.
BILL ALLEY OVER THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP WE
SEVEN ONE OF THE LETTERS
REFERENCED BY THE CHAIR I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING. AND FOR US KHALFAN
LEAVE CONSERVATION VOTERS SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
CLEAN WATER ACTION. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET A
PERSPECTIVE ON THE TIMING OF
THIS I WAS IN THIS ROOM. SEVEN
YEARS AGO ON DOCTORS BUDGET I'M
THE PERSON WALKED IN THERE IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY LEVIN SAID DO
WE FRACKING CALIFORNIA THEY SAID
NO WE DON'T NEED TO. TURNS OUT
THAT WAS NOT TRUE TURNS OUT WE
UNCOVERED LOTS OF STUFF A DOCTOR
THE INADEQUATE. OVERSIGHT OF THE
UNDERGROUND INJECTION CONTROL
PROGRAM INADEQUATE WELL
STANDARDS IN ADEQUATE
ENFORCEMENT THE LIST AND IT
TURNS OUT AN ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT
OF THE UNDERGROUND GAS STORAGE
ISSUE WHICH BLEW UP IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND FOR A ONE YEAR
DOCTOR BATTLED THIS LEGISLATURE
AND THE PUBLIC ADVOCATES LIKE
MYSELF. AND FIND A BECAUSE THEY
WERE IN THE POCKET OF.
THE OIL COMPANIES AND THAT'S THE
WAY IT WAS YOU GOT YOUR PERMITS
QUITE EASILY INCURRING COUNTY.
AND IT'S IRONIC OR I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT IS HERE IS TODAY THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING TO GET
DARKER TO WHAT THEY NEED TO BE.
WORDS IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE
GOVERNOR FIRED. THE DIRECTOR
CONSERVATION THE HEAD OF A
DOCTOR FOR TRYING TO DO WITH
THEIR DOING NOW WHICH IS GET ON
TOP OF THE INDUSTRY NOT IN A BAD
WAY. AS A STATE REGULATORY BODY
WITH ENFORCEMENT ASKING FOR
SCIENCE AND THOSE ARE THE THINGS
THAT SHOP ON OTHERS CAME CAME IN
AND COMPLAINED ABOUT THEN.
SAYING THEY'RE HOLDING UP OUR
PERMITS THIS IS HURTING JOBS IN
KERN COUNTY.
SO YEAH IT TAKES A LITTLE MORE
TIME FOR THESE THINGS BUT DON'T
FORGET THAT THE BIGGEST
INFLUENCE. ON THE RATE OF OIL
PRODUCTION THE STATE AND
MOVEMENT TO MARKETS IS THE PRICE
OF OIL PER BARREL. NOT THE
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT SO NOW
THEY'RE CRYING FOUL. WHEN THE
DOG IS TRYING TO DO WHAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING ALL ALONG
AND IT'S ONLY BEEN DOING AND TO
THEIR CREDIT HAVE COME FORTH
WITH. INITIATIVES BEFORE THIS
BODY ON ENFORCEMENT ORPHAN WELLS
IT'S CETERA. AND NOW BOUGHT
BOBBING LEVELS ARE HIGHER
THEY'RE FINALLY GOING TO DO THE
JOB THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING SO LET'S GET HIM UP TO
WHERE THEY SHOULD BE LIKE OTHER
STATE REGULATORY AGENCIES ARE
DOING A GOOD JOB NOW IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE STATE WATER
BOARD. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BCP'S THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN BLAIR MARK FRENCH MAKER
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND WERE ALSO ASSIGNED HER TO
THE LETTER TO MISTER ELLIOTT WAS
JUST REFERENCING I THINK YOU DID
A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF COVERING
ALL THE TALKING POINTS I WAS
GOING TO BE GIVING HERE SO I'LL
JUST SAY WE ARE IN. SUPPORT OF
THE PEACE PEACE THANK YOU.
MORE MATURE MEMBERS PAY AT THE
THOMAS REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION. LIMITED TO SHED
SOME LIGHT ON MY OPPOSITIONS
COMMENTS FIRST AND FOREMOST MAY
BE VERY CLEAR.
PRODUCTION IS DOWN FIRST OF ALL
LET ME THANK YOU FORHOPE
HOLDING OPEN NINE ITEMS NINE AND
TEN. AS WE WANT TO WORK WITH
THIS AND WORK WITH DOG OR TO THE
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES I WANT TO
TURN THIS INTO A DEBATE NO SO
HIS MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SO IF
YOU COULD.
RESTRICT YOUR COMMENTS TO THE
TESTIMONY THAT'S BEEN HEARD HERE
TODAY YES APPRECIATE THAT WERE
IN SUPPORT OF.
SB SEVEN TWENTY FOUR.
D. OUT A WELL I'M ISSUES
INSOFAR AS WE WORKED ON IT LAST
YEAR WE ALSO KNOW THAT IN FACT.
.
PRODUCTION IS DOWN.
AND WE THINK THAT THE THAT THE
SIZE OF DOG HAS DOUBLED. AND
ONLY THING RESCIND IS NOT
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS THESE ARE
REAL DOLLARS FOR REAL COMPANIES
TWENTY WE'RE ASKING IS THAT WHAT
YOU JUST GRANTED MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND THAT IS A SIMPLE. WORK WITH
DOCKER WE'VE MET BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION WE'VE MET WITH
STAFF MET WITH YOUR STAFF MET
THE DOCTOR. AND WITH THE END OF
THE WE BELIEVE WE'RE GOING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. FOR THE
MORAL SUPERIORITY CALMEST THE
COMMON THAT WERE BAD PEOPLE
THINGS THAT NEED TO THINK IT'S
WRONG. IT JUST SIMPLY IT IS AND
IT HAS TO BE RESPONDED TO MISTER
CHAIRMAN BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
ESPECIALLY IN OUR BUILDING HERE
THE BOTTOM LINE IT IS A REAL
PEOPLE WERE TALKING ABOUT. THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO
DEPEND ON THEIR PAYCHECK TO DO
WHICH IS WHAT EVERYONE IS DOING
HERE SUPPORT THEIR AMILIES AS
ONLY THING WE'RE ASKING. SO FOR
A REPORT TO BE CASTIGATED AS THE
DEMONS I JUST THINK IT'S
IRRELEVANT AND IT SHOULDN'T BE
DONE IN THIS VENUE HERE WHICH
HAVE AN HONEST POLICY DISCUSSION
OR BUT A DISCUSSION. ABOUT WHAT
IS GOING ON SO ANYTHING I WOULD
ASK. IS THAT WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH DOCTOR WE
UNDERSTAND A PRODUCTION IS DOWN
WE HOPE THAT IT WILL GO UP AT
SOME POINT IN TIME BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS.
AT DAY'S END WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
REAL PEOPLE HERE IN REAL
CALIFORNIANS AND IT SEEMS THAT
THE OPPOSITION ON FORGETS THAT
SO THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU OF. SO WE WILL HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN LA O. HAS.
COMMENT SHOWN MY REAL PLEASURE
THAT I THOUGHT THIS FOR FOR
ISSUE NUMBER TEN THE REGULATORY
FIELD INSPECTION. WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ON A THREE YEAR BASIS AND
THERE'S SOME UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
THE AMOUNT OF WORKLOAD THAT
THEY'LL HAVE AND SO. THIS WILL
CAUSE HIM TO COME BACK IN THREE
YEARS AND RE JUSTIFY THE AMOUNT
OF POSITIONS THAT THEY'RE ASKING
FOR RUSS RECOMMENDING THAT YOU
DONT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
REQUIRE THEM TO REPORT ON THE
AMOUNT OF ON THE NUMBER OF.
OILFIELD OPERATIONS THAT THEY
ACTUALLY SENT INSPECTORS OUT TO
OBSERVE IN THE FIELD.
GREAT THANK YOU AND DEPARTMENT
FINANCE ANY COMMENTS S. ENTER
OLD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TIME
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
ALLELES RECOMMENDATION AND
BELIEVE IT'S A REASONABLE
COMPROMISE.
THANK YOU OF MISTER MULLIN OF
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO. ON
THIS ISSUE OF THE PERMIT
BACKLOGS THAT HAS BEEN RAISED.
I HEARD I HEARD YOUR ANSWER.
TO THE QUESTION BUT IF I COULD
JUST FOLLOW WHAT DO YOU THINK
THAT.
THE PERMIT APPROVAL TIME LINE
IS APPROPRIATE YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE HISTORY WHERE.
THINGS ARE BEING APPROVED YOU
QUICKLY WE'RE HEARING THAT
PERMITS ARE NOT BEING APPROVED
IN A TIMELY FASHION DO YOU THINK
THAT.
THE CURRENT PROCESS AND THE
BACKLOG IS APPROPRIATE.
OR. IN TERMS OF YOUR TIME LINE
ARE YOU SATISFIED WITH THE WAY
THINGS ARE OR DO YOU HAVE A PLAN
TO ADDRESS THAT PERMIT BACKLOG
WHICH WOULD.
.
I GUESS INFERS THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM HERE THAT IT IS A SLOW
PROCESS CAN YOU JUST FURTHER.
AMPLIFIER COMMENTS I COULD
UNDERSTAND HUNG WE'RE NOT
SATISFIED WITH THE TIME LINE OR.
THE FACT THAT.
SOME PERMITS HAVE BEEN. TAKEN
VERY LONG TO IMPLEMENT. BUT AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE THERE'S
ACTUALLY. A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO
WITH A MUCH THOROUGH MORE
THOROUGH REVIEW THAT PART OF
THAT TIME THOUGH WHICH WHERE.
THERE'S INEFFICIENCIES AND HOW
WE'VE INTERACTED BACK AND FORTH
WITH THE WATER BOARD AND AND
WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THINGS
INEFFICIENCIES OF HOW WE'VE
REQUESTED INTO ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM INDUSTRY.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
WE CAN DO TO DECREASE THAT
TIMELINE. WE'RE NOT HAPPY WITH
THE TIME WHEN OUR GOAL IS TO DO
A THOROUGH SCIENTIFIC REVIEW IN
THE QUICKEST TIME WE CAN DO
WITHOUT SACRIFICING.
YOU KNOW POTENTIAL THREATS TO
GROUNDWATER CETERA SO I YOU KNOW
I THERE'S CLEARLY SOME EXAMPLES.
WHERE YOU KNOW IT?
THEY'RE NOT GOOD ISN'T ISN'T
EXAMPLES WHERE IT SHOULD HAVE
TAKEN SO LONG TO REVIEW. US SO
WE'RE CONSTANTLY LOOKING AT WAYS
TO MAKE THAT A MORE EFFICIENT
PROCESS. I ONE THING I WILL
POINT OUT JUST IN TERMS THE WITH
THE PRICE OF OIL BEEN MENTIONED
A FEW TIMES AS IF. THEY.
WHEN OIL DROPPED INTO TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN APPLICATIONS
DROPPED IT WASN'T THAT WAY YOU
KNOW AND BUT THEN WHEN YOU KNOW
YOU WHILE OIL PRICES ARE DOWN
THERE RISING AND AS SOON AS THEY
START RISING WE GET A LARGE SLUG
OF APPLICATIONS. SO PART OF THIS
IS IT'S NOT LIKE APPLICATIONS
FOR WOMEN AT A CONSISTENT LEVEL
THEY TO GO UP AND DOWN AND SO
PART OF IT AS. THEY CUT ME CAN'T
IT STARTED COMING IN A RAPID
LEVEL I AND.
AN INNATE AND THEN WHEN THEY
START COMING IN WHEN OUR JUST
BEGINNING ALL THIS A NEW
ADDITIONAL SCIENTIFIC REVIEW OF
THIS LEGISLATURE ASKED ABOUT SO.
I'D SAY THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF.
YOU KNOW LEARNING CURVE GETTING
THE NEW SYSTEMS IN PLACE OF
VALUATION ONE THING THAT'S GONNA
HELP A LOT I MEAN FRANKLY WE'RE
STILL WRESTLING WITH PDS OF
SCIENCE OKAY SO.
WIND AS WELL STAR SYSTEM GET
SAND THAT AND AGAIN IT'S STILL
GOT ABOUT ANOTHER YEAR TO FULLY
GET ALL PHASE TEN. PUTTING BOTH
INDUSTRY IN US WILL BE ABLE TO
SHARE EXCHANGE INFORMATION MORE
RAPIDLY ON THE SCIENCE OF WELLS
IN PROJECTS SO THAT WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT THING. I WOULD SAY FOR
ANOTHER SEVERAL MONTHS THOUGH
WE'RE LITERALLY BEING GOING INTO
THAT TRANSITION FROM.
LIKE PAPER DOCUMENTS GOING BACK
AND FORTH TO REALLY HAVING MORE
THIS ONLINE SO NO I I MEAN WE'RE
NEVER SATISFIED WHEN THINGS TAKE
A LONG TIME.
SO IT'S UP.
IT'S A NEW DAY A DAUGHTER AND A
BAD AND.
.
THERE'S.
MULTIPLE FACTORS IN THE EQUATION
HERE THERE'S THE MARKET
DYNAMICS.
YOU FOLKS ARE TRYING TO RESPOND
TO THESE MANDATES THAT WE'RE
PUTTING ON YOU.
.
WHAT I'M CURIOUS ABOUT IT AND
THIS IS A GENUINE QUESTION HAVE
NO IDEA IS THERE OR SHOULD THERE
BE A RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
LEVEL OF PRODUCTION WHICH IS
DRIVEN BY A VARIETY OF FACTORS
BUT THE LEVEL OF PRODUCTION?
DOMESTICALLY IN CAL WITHIN
STATE.
AND YOUR STAFFING LEVELS IN
TERMS OF YOUR. ENFORCEMENT SO
THERE YOU KNOW TWENTY SEVEN NEW
POSITIONS.
WE'RE GONNA BE STAFFING UP I
THINK.
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY. I SUPPORT.
STAFFING UP TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
WE'RE MEETING OUR OBLIGATIONS
THAT WE THE LEGISLATURE PUT ON
YOU BUT.
IS THERE AT.
.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN YOUR
STAFFING LEVELS AND THE LEVEL OF
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA WORSE
ARE THOSE TWO THINGS KIND OF.
NON LINEAR THOSE ARE ON THERE
NOT LINEAR SO FOR EXAMPLE
WHETHER IF PEOPLE FOR EXAMPLE OF
A REDUCTION APPLICATIONS ARE
WORK RELATED DOWN. BUT IF
PEOPLE'S YOUNG THROTTLE BACK ON
HOW MUCH THEY'RE PRODUCING WE
STILL HAVE TO REGULATE THOSE
WELL HAS WHETHER THEY'RE ACTIVE
IN ACTIVE. WE STILL HAVE TO DO
SEEMS INSPECTIONS SO THE
WORKLOAD FRANKLY FOR US WE STILL
HAVE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND WELLS.
TO TO MANAGE AND REVIEW SO THEY
THE. THE WORKLOAD DOESN'T GO
DOWN UP AND DOWN LIKE THAT WHEN
PRODUCTION GOES UP AND DOWN.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE SOMEONE LEAN TO IS WHEN
PRODUCTION GOES DOWN. THE AMOUNT
OF COST PER BARREL. IN ITSELF
WILL GO UP A LITTLE IN THE FEES.
BUT.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE SO SO I
DON'T THINK IT IS THAT CONNECTED
I MEAN IT BECAUSE WE'RE STILL
HAVING TO MANAGE THE SAME NUMBER
OF WELLS AND PROJECTS. I IF.
PRODUCTION WENT WAY UP OUR
WORKLOAD INCREASE AS MORE YOU
KNOW MORE ADS STRAWS ARE PUT IN
THE GROUND SO TO SPEAK.
SO I IT'S.
NOT THAT IT'S HIGHLY RELATED
BECAUSE A REGARDLESS OF WHAT'S
GOING ON TO WELL WE STILL HAVE
TO REGULATE IT CHECK BLOWOUT
PREVENTERS INSPECT AMON ALL LIKE
I THINK. BECAUSE THOSE
INSPECTIONS AROUND SCHEDULES YOU
KNOW TO KEEP THINGS SAFE NOT ON
WHETHER HOW MUCH THEY'RE PUMPING
AT A GIVEN TIME.
AND I WILL BELIEVE AT THIS
POINT.
ANYMORE MISTER CHAIR BUT.
MY.
UNEDUCATED NON EXPERT UP.
VIEW OF OIL IN CALIFORNIA FROM
WHAT I'VE HEARD IS THAT. THERE
WERE PROMISES OF LOTS OF
PRODUCTION WITH MODERATION ALE
BUT.%
AS FOLKS. YOU KNOW DID THE
FRACKING AND REALLY GOT INTO IT
IT SORT OF. DIDN'T REALLY
MATERIALIZE TO THE EXTENT THAT.
THE INDUSTRY HOPED LET'S PUT IT
THAT WAY. IS THAT IS THAT
ACCURATE AS WANT TO KNOW THAT MY
OWN KIND OF FRAMING ON THIS. IS
ACCURATELY WHAT IS THE STATE OF
OF PRODUCTION.
FROM YOUR STANDPOINT. IN IN
CALIFORNIA AND SORT OF
PROJECTING GOING FORWARD YOU
KNOW AT THERE WAS A MOMENT THERE
WERE PEOPLE THAT THERE SHOULD BE
NEW OIL BOOM OR SOMETHING IN
CALIFORNIA. IN BAND WHO IS MY
FORMER LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
KNOWS TONS MORE ABOUT THIS THAN
I DO BUT IT AND MY INFORMATION
WAS. FROM HIM BUT IS THAT STILL.
KIND OF THERE IS THAT THE STATE
OF AFFAIRS IN CALIFORNIA WITH MY
BREAK A BRIEF COMMENT IF YOU
WANT MORE I COULD ASK OUR CHIEF
DEPUTY OIL SUPERVISORS HERE BOB
MARLEY. WHO IS BASED IN KERN
COUNTY I MIGHT ASK CAN COME UP
BUT? GENERALLY IT'S FALLING
PRICE I MEAN YOU KNOW REGARDLESS
OF YOU KNOW.
WHAT TECHNIQUES ARE USED IT WHEN
PRICE WENT DOWN PRODUCTIONS GONE
DOWN AND INVESTMENT GOES DOWN
NUMBER RIGS IN THE STATE GOES
DOWN? RIGHT NOW ACTUALLY NEVER
RIGGS IS GOING UP AND YOU KNOW
SO.
AND.
I YOU KNOW WHEN WE CAN'T I
CANNOT I DO FEEL LIKE A MORE
DETAILED ANALYSIS SO IT BUT WHEN
SO IT'S DRIVEN BY THE PRICE. NOT
NECESSARILY THE CONDITIONS.
IN THE GROUND.
WELL IT'S BOTH I MEAN IF I EVER
BUY. IT.
YOU THINK IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE TO
REMOVE IT DOWN THAT PRICE HAS TO
BE HIGHER TO GET IT OUT OF THE
GROUND. SO I'M YOU KNOW BUT IT
STILL MOVES WITH PRICE.
BY A MIGHT BE.
LESS OF THE OIL IS.
ECONOMIC TO PULL OUT OF THE
GROUND.
WHEN PRICES GO DOWN AND AND AND
AND MAYBE NOT AS ECONOMICAL
YEARS AGO WHEN IT WAS EASIER TO
GET OUT OF THE GROUND. SO IT IS
STILL FLUCTUATES WITH PRICE
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
RIGHT AS A CLOSING COMMENT AT A
PLACE SO I JUST LIKE WANT ME TO
COMMENTS IS.
LAST WEEK A P. RAN A NATION WIDE
ARTICLE ABOUT. THE FACT THAT.
THERE WAS LIKE FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY THREE VIOLATIONS IN
COASTAL AND OFFSHORE FACILITIES
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT RAN
NATIONWIDE FORTUNATE THE STORY
DIDN'T. THEY DIDN'T TAKE ENOUGH
TIME TO LET US. LOOKS AT HOW
MANY OF THOSE WE'VE VERIFIED
HAVE COMPLIED AND FIX THE
PROBLEM. BUT OF THOSE OF A
FOREIGN FIVE HUNDRED FORTY THREE
A HUNDRED ALL BUT A HUNDRED FOUR
HAD BEEN EITHER TAKEN OUT OF
PRODUCTION ORDER VERIFIED WITH
COMPLIANCE. SO THAT LEAVES IS
BASICALLY NINETEEN PERCENT OF
THOSE.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
GO VERIFY. THEY'VE ACTUALLY
COMPLIED WITH THE VIOLATION
ORDER I MEAN THE. NOTICE OF
VIOLATION THAT THEY NEED TO FIX
SOMETHING.
AND I LITERALLY IS TO DEAL WITH
ONE OF THE BODIES TO GO OUT AND
AND SEE A WALL SETS IN THAT CASE
IT WAS NINETEEN PERCENT OR A
HUNDRED FOUR OF THEM. NOW THEY
MAY HAVE COMPLIED WE DON'T KNOW
WE USED TO HAVE PEOPLE TO GO OUT
AND SEE IT. IN THE LAST TWO
SHOWS ONE MADE ABOUT THE FEE IS
THAT.
WE'RE ACTUALLY BELOW ALL THE
OTHER MAJOR OIL PRODUCING STATES
IN THE SIZE OF OUR FEE FOR OUR
OIL REGULATORY SYSTEM WE'RE NOT
IN AN UNUSUAL WAY. WE'RE NOT
UNUSUAL AT ALL AND.
IT'S OUR INTENT THAT WE HOPE THE
FEES GO DOWN I WANT ONE OF
THINGS I MENTION THAT IS FOR
EXAMPLE I THINK IN THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS IT PROBABLY WILL GO
DOWN A LITTLE BIT. BECAUSE THIS
WELL STAR PROGRAM WAS A BIG
BUBBLE OF COST IT WAS TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR.
FIFTEEN THIS YEAR IT'LL BE FIVE
NEXT YEAR BUT YOU AND THAT IS
GONNA GET DOWN TO ABOUT ONE
POINT THREE. SO IT'LL BE A YOUNG
TURNS ON GOING SO BUT IT WAS
THIS HUGE BUBBLE OF COST THAT
THIS HE IS PAYING FOR. SO THERE
WOULD LIKELY WILL BE A DECREASE
IN THE IN THE IN THE REQUIRED.
DOLLARS FOR DOING OUR JOB NOW.
ALSO THAT FEES WILL BE AFFECTED
BY IS AFFECTED BY HOW THE PRICE
IS. NOT A PRODUCTION. BUT I JUST
WANT TO SHARE THAT I DON'T THINK
WE'RE AN UNUSUAL STAY IN FACT
WE'VE BEEN BELOW OTHER STATES IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE CHARGE FOR
REGULATORY PROGRAM.
AND TWO THAT WE STILL HAVE WORK
TO DO TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN PLAN
A INSURE THAT OPERATORS.
ARE OPERATING SAFELY AND AND
THE ONLY WAY TO DO THAT IS TO
HAVE INSPECTORS AND ENFORCEMENT
TEAM.
THANKS SO.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THAT
NINETEENPERCENT YEAH.
THAT WERE OUT OF COMPLIANCE OUT
OF THE FIVE I KNOW IT WAS FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY THREE VIOLATIONS
THAT WE ISSUED. AND. OF THOSE.
ARE ALL ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FOUR
WE EITHER VERIFIED THE FIX THE
PROBLEM WORD THEY WERE TAKEN OUT
OF PRODUCTION FOR EXAMPLE.
IT'S QUITE AN ABOUT HALF AS WELL
ABOUT IT. TO ABOUT A. FORTY
PERCENT OF THOSE ARE TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY EIGHT RUN RINCON
ISLANDER PLATFORM HOLLY WHICH
WITH THE STATES TAKING BACK
CONTROL OF RINCON ISLAND IS NOW
REMEDIATING THE ISLAND. AND
PLATFORM HOLLY IS YOU KNOW
BASICALLY BEING REMEDIATED NOT
PRODUCING WELL I I WANT TO FOCUS
ON THE HUNDRED AND SEATTLE HER
FOR A.
WHAT IS THE PLAN FOR ADDRESSING
THOSE OF? HOW MUCH I DON'T THINK
IT'S?
IT WILL BE OUR GOAL IS TO GET
OUT TO ME AS SOON AS WE CAN WITH
THE STAFF THAT WE HAVE I MEAN I
I THINK WE HAVE A CHART HERE IT
SAYS HOW MANY THINK
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED.
.
WELL HEADS PER INSPECTOR WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THAT DOWN TO ABOUT
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED WELL HAD SPRING
SPECTER.
SO THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM JUST
THE COAST AS A PROBLEM STATEWIDE
IT WE WE LACK ADEQUATE
INSPECTORS. TO FULLY GO OUT
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH
VIOLATIONS.
IS THERE A A TIME LINE WITHIN
WHICH YOU THINK.
BILL I CAN I CAN I I'D BE HAPPY
GET BACK TO YOU IN A DAY OR TWO
SAYING HOW FAST WE CAN LOOK AT
THESE REMAINING HUNDRED FOUR.
FIVE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN CLOSE
LISTER.
OKAY COASTAL IN AND A LOS
ANGELES DISTRICT THAT WOULD BE
GREAT THANK YOU.
THE THIRD SAID NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR.
YOU'RE ALWAYS ELIMINATING
TESTIMONY SINGER. OF ALWAYS
THOUGHT PROVOKING AS AS AS WELL.
OF.
AND.
WILL HOLD THE AS I SAID ISSUES.
.
NINE AND TEN THANK YOU WILL HOLD
THOSE ITEMS OPEN BUT THAT LEAVES
US WITH THE ISSUE EIGHT TO.
FOR WHICH WE HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE HIS
BUDGET IS OUR MOTION.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND.
PHOTO ON THAT LITTLE ISSUE EIGHT
I.
FALL.
CHOLERA MOLEN.
PATTERSON.
NINE INTEND TO HOLD OPEN AND
ISSUE ELEVEN AGAIN THERE'S A
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE AS
BUDGET SURPLUS.
MOTION IS MADE AND SECONDED
THANK YOU HELLO.
I FALL.
CHOLERA MOLEN.
AND. THEN THE FINALLY ON ISSUE
TWELVE THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVE AS REQUESTED FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN THAT
BUDGET HERE.
MOVED AND SECONDED HELLO I FALL.
CHOLERA MOMENT.
SINCE I.
AND NOW LET'S GO BACK TO.
ISSUE SIX UNDER DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE WE DEFERRED
TO.
THAT ITEM.
ISSUE SIX THE RECOMMENDATION I
THINK IS APPROVED AS BUDGET IS
THAT RIGHT.
I HAVE A MOTION. I'LL SECOND
THAT.
BLOOM I FALL.
ALRIGHT MOLEN.
PERCENT.
ALRIGHT WE'LL AWAIT MR KARAS
ARRIVAL FOR ISSUE SIX.
AND TED THAT LEAVES US WITH THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
IT'S A LITTLE COMPLICATED TODAY
BECAUSE IT'S SO LONG BUT.
LET ME SEE IF THERE'S A MOTION
ON ISSUES.
ONE THROUGH FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY TWO.
TWENTY FOUR THROUGH TWENTY
SEVEN.
THIRTY ONE OR THIRTY FOUR.
THIRTY SIX.
THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY NINE THROUGH
FORTY TWO.
FORTY FOUR THROUGH FIFTY. AND
FIFTY TWO
THREE SIXTY THREE.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
HELLO.
I FALL.
CHOLERA MOLEN.
PERSON.
NOW IS THERE A MOTION ON ISSUES
SIXTEEN.
FOR ONLY.
SO.
THANK YOU SECOND.
BLOOM I FALL.
CHOLERA MOLEN.
PATTERSON.
MAY I HEAR A MOTION ON. ISSUE
TWENTY THREE.
I'LL SECOND THAT.
BLOOM I.
FALL.
CHOLERA MOLEN.
PATTERSON.
IS THERE A MOTION ON ISSUES
TWENTY EIGHT THROUGH THIRTY.
OF.
SECOND BLOOM I FALL.
COVER MALEN.
PATTERSON.
RIGHT.
OKAY.
ISSUE THIRTY FIVE IS OUR MOTION.
SECOND.
LO I FALL.
CHOLERA MOLEN.
PATTERSON.
ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT.
IS OUR MOTION.
SO.
SECOND BLOOM I FALL.
CHOLERA MOLEN.
PERSON NO.
DURING HER EMOTIONAL ISSUE FORTY
THREE.
SECOND.
HELLO I FALL.
COVER MOLEN.
PATTERSON.
FINALLY A IS OUR MOTION ON ISSUE
FIFTY ONE.
THE SECOND. BLOW I FALL.
CHOLERA.
MULLEN.
FIVE. PERCENT.
THANK YOU WE WILL LAUGH HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN.
FOR MR KARA.
I HOPE THEY'LL GET HERE SO
SEVENTEEN THROUGH TWENTY TO
TWENTY FOURTH OR TWENTY SEVEN.
THIRTY ONE THROUGH THIRTY FOUR
THIRTY SIX THREE THIRTY SEVEN
THIRTY NINE OR FORTY TO FORTY
FOUR THROUGH FIFTY. FIFTY TWO
THROUGH SIXTY THREE CURRENT
VOTE.
FIVE FOUR OH.
KALRA.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE SIXTEEN CURRENT
VOTE TO TO TO KALRA BY.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE TWENTY THREE CAR
VOTE TO TO KALRA.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE THIRTY THREE
THIRTY FIVE ME AT TWO TWO KALRA
BY.
ISSUE VOTE ONLY THIRTY EIGHT
CURRENT VOTE TO TO TO KALRA.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE FORTY THREE
CURRENT VOTE TO TO KALRA.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE FIFTY ONE
CURRENT VOTE IS TO TO KALRA.
VOTE ONLY ISSUES TWENTY THROUGH
THIRTY CURRENT VOTE FOR OAK
KALRA.
ITEMS TO BE HEARD ISSUE ONE
CRIME VOTE TO TO KALRA.
ISSUED THREE CURRENT VOTE THREE
OH KALRA.
I'M ISSUE. POPSICLES CURRENT
VOTE TO TO KALRA.
ISSUE A CURRENT VOTE FOR.
KALRA.
THANK YOU HOPE.
SORRY TO MARK ISSUE ELEVEN
CURRENT VOTE FOR . KALRA.
ISSUE TWELVE CRIME VOTE FOR HOPE
KALRA.
HERE'S.
WE ARE ADJOURNED